Diese Klänge signalisieren ganz eindeutig. Es ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat. Wir haben nämlich den 26. November 2008. Und immer wenn ihr Kraftwerk läuft, am Mittwoch um 22 Uhr, heißt das, es ist Zeit fürs Chaos Radio auf Fritz mit dem Chaos Computer Club, zu dem ihr herzlich begrüßt seid. Heute sind hier Dennis Krüggs, Erdgeist und mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Guten Abend. Krüggs, kann ich dich hören? Alter, das ist total super. Das ist nicht nur das Chaos Radio Nummer 141, was ihr heute hier hört, sondern auch ein ganz besonderes, denn es ist das letzte Chaos Radio in diesem Jahr. Nächstes Mal im Dezember gibt es wie immer kein Chaos Radio, denn es findet ja der Kongress statt, vom 27. bis zum 30. Dezember. Über den wir euch nachher noch aufklären werden. Wenn ihr da jetzt schon dringend gucken möchtet, dann tut das einfach unter ccc.de, wo auch alle anderen Infos rund um den Chaos Computer Club zu finden sind. Thema der Sendung heute ist Geschichte und Technik von BitTorrent-Programmen.
Genau.
Ist das richtig, so zusammengefasst?
Wir müssen über die Geschichte erzählen und wie es halt funktioniert, weil viele Leute wissen es halt noch nicht.
Okay, die erste Assoziation, die heute auch hier so im Laufe des Tages immer wieder durch den Raum spielt, war BitTorrent. Ah ja, da kann man so Daten durchs Netz tauschen. Das sind so Schnipsel. Das ist ein bisschen anders als bei den normalen P2P-Programmen früher und es ist total sicher. Und darüber werden wir heute im Laufe der kommenden zwei Stunden reden. Wir werden da eine Menge Sachen aufklären und auch wieder gerade rücken. Wenn ihr da Beteiligung habt, wenn ihr mitreden wollt, wenn ihr Fragen habt, dann könnt ihr euch gerne an dieser Sendung beteiligen unter der 0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110. Wir werden versuchen, eure Fragen zu beantworten. Oder aber ihr geht online auf www.ccc.de oder aber fritz.de, da gibt es die Adressen und da könnt ihr gerne euch auch an diesem Chaosradio beteiligen. Bevor wir zum Thema BitTorrent eigentlich kommen, sollten wir klären, wo kommt BitTorrent her und warum gibt es das heutzutage? Also ein bisschen den Weg zur heutigen BitTorrent-Technologie beschreiben, damit wir wissen, warum es das eigentlich gibt.
Das war circa 2000, 2001 gab es ein Projekt, das hieß Modulation, das sollte das Überprotokoll für File Sharing werden, ist aber irgendwie an vielen kleinen Dingen gescheitert und ein Programmierer davon, nämlich der Bram Cohen, ist irgendwie ausgestiegen und hat sich selber was überlegt und der hat dann das BitTorrent-Protokoll entwickelt.
Lass mal noch an zwei Schritte früher anfangen, weil das Wort File Sharing ist gerade gefallen, Mojo ist das eine, aber natürlich sind Files, also Daten, viele, viele Jahre vorher im letzten Jahrtausend auch anders getauscht worden, also entweder habe ich dir eine Diskette oder ein Stick oder eine CD oder ein wunderbares kleines Magnetband gegeben und du hast das dann mit mehr oder weniger großem Aufwand vervielfältig oder an den nächsten weitergerückt. Das ist ja in Zeiten von schnellem Internet nur wirklich Schnee von Uhr vorgestern.
Richtig, mit dem Internet kamen dann Sachen wie FTP oder ein HTTP-Download und...
Ach, das ist sowieso schon alles noch moderner Scheiße. Ich meine, ganz früher hat man sich zu Hause so sein Modem angeschlossen und dann mit einer Mailbox gesprochen und dann so die Files, die man da hochladen, also meistens waren das G-Packs gewesen, so die ersten Bilder in heutzutage noch klitzeklein, so 30 Kilobyte und auf die Mailbox hoch und da konnte man nur einer gleichzeitig und so fing das damals an, Files zu sharen, Dateien auszutauschen. Aber das ist der Urschleim und die meisten Leute werden das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr kennen und haben wahrscheinlich niemals ein Modem besessen, genauso wie sie eine Diskette besessen haben.
Und lasst euch sagen, ihr wollt es auch nicht zurück haben.
Nee, war schlimm. Also während man was runtergeladen hat, konnte man noch nicht mehr chatten, weil entweder oder.
Genau. Und wir würden ja von euch da draußen gerne wissen, wie ihr eure erste Datei getauscht habt, ob ihr das noch per Diskette auf dem Schulhof gemacht habt oder dann doch schon über eins der Filesharing-Protokolle. Die Telefonnummer ist?
0331 70 97 110, selbstverständlich für euch zu mitmachen. 0331 Potsdamer Vorwahl 70 97 110. Also von der Diskette zum Filesharing-Programm zu BitTorrent im Jahre 2008. Das ist das Thema der heutigen Sendung. Wollen wir ein bisschen weiter in den Anfängen von BitTorrent, warum gibt es das noch ein bisschen rumkramen, Dennis? Das ist glaube ich zum Verständnis ganz gut.
Ja, das Hauptproblem vorher war, sagen wir, wir nehmen jetzt schon was moderneres wie FTP, war das ein Server, der Dateien für FTP-Download bereitstellt, wenn 100 Leute was runtergeladen haben. Dann musste der Server das auch 100 Mal ausliefern. Er hatte natürlich viel zu tun. Bei 1000 Leuten wurde es langsam schwierig und bei 10 und 10.000 noch mehr Leuten war es denn eigentlich fast unmöglich, damals jedenfalls. Deswegen hatte man die Idee, dass alle Leute, die was runterladen, die besitzen ja auch diese Informationen, könnten die ja auch weiter verteilen und daraus ist die Idee zu Peer-to-Peer entstanden, dass jeder, der was hat, auch schon mit allen anderen, die es auch wollen, tauschen kann, sodass sich alle beteiligen und insgesamt man die Effektivität der Verteilung erhöhen kann.
Dass die ganze Geschichte nicht nur einseitig funktioniert, also du hast ein Foto, das will ich gerne haben, ich ziehe mir das von dir runter, bis das Ding da ist. Es sind ja immer schon Bruchteile dieser Datei, die langsam so reingelaufen kommen.
Das können wir dann gleich erklären wie BitTorrent es auch nochmal aufstückelt, damit das besser funktioniert.
Kann man sagen, dass BitTorrent im Allgemeinen sowieso schneller ist als alles das, was es vorher gab? Und besser und toller und überhaupt der falsche Zweifel?
Insgesamt würde ich das glaube ich jahen im Einzelfall nicht. Also wenn du einen dicken schnellen FTP Server hast, der hat irgendwie gar kein Overhead, du kriegst das Zeug direkt entgegengeballert, dann ist das total flott. Aber wenn es halt tausend Leute von diesem einen FTP Server haben wollen, dann schafft der das halt irgendwann nicht mehr und dann ist es halt Feierabend und dann kommt halt BitTorrent. Und heutzutage interessiert es nicht mehr, wenn einer drei Sachen runterladen will oder drei kleine Files, das mache ich von meinem Rechner zu Hause, das ist sowieso egal. Das interessiert mir nur noch die riesengroßen Geschichten.
Wir haben den ersten Anrufer schon zur Frage von den Eltern, die in den Raum kamen, wie habt ihr eure ersten Daten ausgetauscht und zwar Christian. Wieso kann ich mit dem noch nicht reden? Christian?
Trau dich.
Ja, hallo. Guten Abend, wir hatten gerade hier noch ein Problem, dein File auf unser File raufzuscheren. Guten Abend, grüß dich. Die Frage, die rausging, ist, wie hat bei dir Filesharing angefangen?
Ja, also wenn ich mich recht erinnere, war das damals dieser MDR Computer Club und da konnte man mit Saugnoppen, den man so auf den Fernseher geheftet hat, per schwarz-weißen Bildpunkten so eine Datei runterladen. Also das war so ziemlich mein erster Erfahrung, wie ich damit gemacht hab.
Bo, wie cool. Darf ich fragen, wie alt du bist?
39.
NDR Saugnoppen auf dem Fernseher, das klingt wie fies, frühe 70er Jahre.
Ja, ich glaube, das war mit so einer Fotozelle irgendwie und dann haben die praktisch immer so nur so ein helles Quadrat gehabt, man musste das auf so eine bestimmte Ecke auf dem Bildschirm heften und während der gesamten Sendung, also diese 45 Minuten, konnte man halt da, wo der Saugnoppen war, nix sehen, aber die Sendung, also die kann man da trotzdem sehen, weil nur dieser kleine Saugnoppen, der da am Fernseher heftete.
Wie hast du deiner ersten Datei jemanden anders übergeholfen? Ich meine, da hast du ja nur was heruntergeladen.
Na, ich glaube, das erste war so Akustikkoppler, also Quattisch-Telefonhörer. Damals konnte man ja in Berlin noch kostenlos telefonieren, auch von jeder Telefonzelle.
Das war immer 23 Pfennig bezahlt pro Anruf.
Ja, genau. Und dann konnte man, weiß ich nicht, endlos telefonieren auf jeden Fall. Da gab es auch noch die Mauer.
Und?
Ja, weiß ich nicht mehr, aber es war kein JPEG und kein ZIP und sonst was, weil es gab es damals alles noch gar nicht. Also damals, die ersten Dateien waren eigentlich so, ich sehe ja nicht ungen, aber es war garantiert ein Spiel für einen C64, Loadrunner oder sowas oder Bar of the Dead.
Das war also eine Raubkopie.
Ja, das war von einem Freund, der die gekauft hat, der die dann weitergegeben hat. Nö, dann durfte man damals sozusagen Freunden und Bekannten, ich glaube bis zu sechs Leuten waren das, durfte man die Dateien, also wenn man eine Zoom MusikCD gekauft hat oder einen Spiegel gekauft hat, weil man den anderen schenken wollte, da war das Markenrecht noch nicht, also ich weiß nicht, das Raubkopierrecht scheinbar noch nicht so hart. Auf jeden Fall bis zu sechs Leuten und Freunden und Bekannten durfte man weitergeben.
Du sprichst jetzt gerade einen ganz interessanten Punkt an, Christian, und zwar fiel das Wort ja auch schon Raubkopie, Sicherheitskopie, tralala. Immer wenn das Wort Filesharing fällt, ist das erste, was den Leuten einfällt, Computer werden daran getauscht. Das zweite, was der halben Welt dazu einfällt, ist, oh, da gehen wir in lauter illegale Dinge durch Netz geschickt. Genau, da sollten wir jetzt vielleicht dazu sagen, dass Filesharing nicht hauptsächlich dazu da ist, damit Leute eine CD kaufen und die dann ein milliardenfaches Netz stellen, sondern dass Filesharing und BitTorrent hauptsächlich dazu da ist, um große Datenmengen innerhalb von kurzer Zeit an sehr viele Leute weiterzugeben. World of Warcraft Patch ist, glaub ich, ein Stichwort, was bei vielen von euch jetzt klingeln sollte. Vielleicht zockt ihr das Spiel auch gerade. Das letzte Update ging ja auch per BitTorrent.
Sie benutzen schon genau so die Welt.
Microsoft bietet doch zum Auflau... Weil die sind für mich immer so die Vorreiter dessen, wenn die das machen sozusagen, dann ist es ja nach dem Motto, dann ist es ja Gott, der das macht. Bei denen zum Beispiel ist das ja so. Die bieten ja auch ISOs und derartige Dateien zum Download an, also um jetzt irgendwelche, sag ich mal, CDs runterzuladen.
Aber die wollten ja auch noch ein Konkurrenzprodukt zu BitTorrent erfinden. Das war irgendwie Avalanche, das ist vor drei Jahren mal rausgekommen, aber ist so nicht richtig was geworden.
So richtig funktioniert hat es nie.
Nee, wollte keiner haben. Warum?
Soll aber, sollte aber wohl gut sein, weil gibt's ja nicht mehr.
Christian, wie machst du das heutzutage? Also von den Akustik- und den Optik-Kopplern haben wir jetzt schon gehört. Wie machst du das heute?
Naja, am liebsten würde ich es über, also machen würde ich es am liebsten im Moment über Kabelmodem. Weil das für mich hier in Berlin das Schnellste wäre. Aber da jetzt ums hier geht es nicht mehr. Das sind 30.000 da.
Aber welche Protokolle benutzt du? Also du redest ja nur von Medium.
Das ist jetzt, um Daten zu tauschen beispielsweise, hauptsächlich eigentlich HTTP. Also ich lege die Sachen auf meiner Website ab, wenn jemand haben möchte. Sozusagen die, die ich zum Download anbiete, sei es Programme, die ich programmiere, die lege ich halt zum Download da ab. Und die kann derjenige dann runterladen.
Das ist für die meisten die einfachste Art. Aber das ist ja dann immer nur für einen was, wenn du was hast, was an, sagen wir mal, 10.000 Leute verteilen willst.
Geh ich ehrlich zu, hab ich selten.
Aber vielleicht kommt es noch und möglicherweise gibt diese Sendung dir dann dazu noch Inspiration. Christian, alles klar, schönen Abend noch, danke dir. 0331 70 97 110, das ist die Nummer vom Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir reden heute über BitTorrent und Filesharing. Wir haben die Geschichte noch nicht so richtig, noch nicht so richtig komplett zu Ende erzählt.
Von dem BitTorrent?
Genau.
Wir waren bei Bram Kohn, wolltest du da weitermachen?
Wir können ja erst mal erzählen, dass mit Nutella ja vorher schon noch ein anderer Versuch, Peer-to-Peer-Software zu schreiben, nahe einigermaßen fehlgeschlagen ist, weil Nutella hatte das Problem gehabt, dass die in ihr Netzwerk neben dem eigentlichen Austausch der Dateien auch noch die Suche da mit reingetan haben. Und damit ist, wenn du nachts mal ohne irgendwas zu tun den Nutella Client angemacht hast, ist am nächsten Morgen mehrere Gigabyte Daten schon ausgetauscht, ohne dass du irgendwas runtergeladen hast.
Lass uns doch mal ganz kurz ein Stückchen zurückrudern. Du hast Nutella gerade angesprochen. Christian sagt ja eben, er hat einen File auf seiner Webseite. Und wenn das jemand haben will, dann kannst du dir das ziehen. Also quasi eins zu eins. Ich gehe auf seine Webseite und suche mir das.
Die meisten Leute haben ja keine eigene Webseite. Dann müssen sie so was benutzen wie vielleicht RapidShare oder wo man so Dateien hochkriegt.
Also du kriegst irgendwo eine Datei, wo dann drauf steht, wo dann eine Webseite, wo dann irgendwie drauf steht. Ein Link, hier bitte downloaden, fertig. Das ist ja dann bei Systemen wie Nutella schon ein bisschen anders gewesen.
Genau, da hat man sich dann einfach mit jemand anders verbunden, deren Netzwerkadresse man auch aus diesem Netzwerk irgendwie merkisch bekommen hat. Man hat sich an so ein paar Rechnern verbunden, die so Listen bereitgehalten haben. Und da sieht man auch schon das Problem, dass erstens, wenn diese Rechner abgeschaltet werden, wo es die Listen von Nutella-Kunden gibt, dann kann man da nicht mehr hinconnecten. Und danach gab es natürlich das große Problem, dass Nutella ziemlich viel Overhead hatte. Also so Verwaltungsdaten, die man austauschen musste, ohne dass man auch noch das erste Byte runtergeladen hat.
Damit der eine Computer erst mal weiß, dass der andere Computer existiert.
Existiert und welche Dateien er so anbietet auf seiner Festplatte. Und man musste dann die ganze Ordner aufmachen, in die man dann der Welt gezeigt hat. Da ist natürlich auch mal viel schiefgegangen, dass man da seine privaten und eigentlich nicht für die Öffentlichkeit bestimmten Ordner dann geteilt hat.
Also eine ganz frühe Variation vom Thema File Sharing, die mehrere Löcher sowohl für die Privatsphäre hatte, als auch irgendwann natürlich für Datenmengen.
Ja, war schon mal eigentlich ein guter Start. Da ging es dann so langsam los. Dann dachten Leute noch, das müssen wir jetzt noch besser machen. Aber die Richtung war schon mal super.
Wie kam es dann zu den... Ich versuche mal diesen Zeitfahrt noch mal hochzuhalten. Wie kam es dann also von Dingern wie Nutella, oder aber Limeware oder Casar, oder wie sie alle heißen, zu den BitTorrent Systemen?
Irgendwann wurde dann ganz klar, dass die Suche einfach nicht mit ins Protokoll gehört. Sodass es Anbieter gibt, wie zum Beispiel Google, die das mit der Suche deutlich besser drauf haben. Und haben dann einfach gesagt, dann tun wir da einfach eine extra Wolke für jedes Fall was verteilen wollen. Das war so die Idee von BitTorrent. Das heißt, dass so BitTorrent-Runterlader, die sich so zusammentun und eine Datei haben wollen, die sind genau eine einzige Wolke und wissen halt auch nur von dieser Datei und von nichts anderem. Und du kannst so in ein Programm, mehrere sogenannte Torrents, wo die Informationen darüber drinstehen, über die Datei, die eigentlich geteilt werden soll, da kannst du die reintun. Und dann finden sich die Leute untereinander und können dann über diese Verbindung auch nur genau diese Datei austauschen.
Okay, um das nochmal bildlich zu machen. Also wir haben jetzt hier mehrere Rechner, die sich und die sich zusammenfinden in einem Netzwerk. Und jeder hat eine bestimmte Information oder einen Schnipsel der Information und die werden alle hin und her getauscht. Was genau ist jetzt dieses Torrent? Ich mache jetzt absichtlich hier die Idiotenfrage, um das immer wieder mal runter zu holen, sonst wären wir extrem technisch. Also was genau ist dieses Torrent, von dem du eben sprachst?
Na die Torrent-Datei selber, die erkennt man an einer Endungpunkt-Torrent, da steht Informationen über diese Datei drin.
Das ist aber nicht die Datei selber?
Das ist noch nicht die Datei selber, nein, das sind nur sogenannte Meta-Informationen und da steht drinne, wie groß die ist. Da stehen so ein paar Checksummen drinne von einzelnen Blöcken dieser Datei. Diese Checksummen, das ist so ein kryptographischer Fingerabdruck von jeweils einem Ausschnitt des Files. Und die Idee dabei ist, dass man braucht ja irgendeine kleinste Einheit, bei der man ganz sicher sagen kann, dass man jetzt die Datei vollständig runtergeladen hat, oder einen Teil der Datei sicher runtergeladen hat. Und das kann man, wenn man so einen Fingerabdruck des Blocks hat, kann man nachgucken, ja ich hab jetzt so den ersten 64. zum Beispiel runtergeladen. Und müsste jetzt, wenn ich da die Checksumme drüber berechne, müsste die so und so aussehen. Und die steht dann auch in dieser Punktorrent-Datei drin.
Also abgesehen von den ganzen Checksummen und den Details, die in so einem Torrent-Ding drinstehen, klingt das alles total einfach. So als ob jeder, der in den Computerladen geht und sich da irgendwo einen fertig gebauten Rechner kauft, das Ding anschließen kann und sagen kann, das will ich jetzt auch machen.
Ist es auch. Muss er ja nicht viel für können.
Was muss er denn dafür können?
Da muss man sich eigentlich nur einen Torrent-Client herunterladen. Da muss man sich runterladen, da sucht man sich. Dann kann man ja Google übernehmen. Und wenn man diesen Torrent-Client hat, dann sagt man, sucht man sich entweder Torrent-Files im Netz, per Google oder über andere Suchseiten. Und wenn man selber was sharen will, dann muss man meistens nur dem Torrent-Programm sagen, share jetzt bitte diese Datei.
Also sharen heißt, dass du die, dass du sie selber auch verteilst und nicht nur Sachen andicht.
Ich hab jetzt selber einen Film gemacht und möchte den Leuten da draußen zeigen. Dann sagt man seinem Torrent-Programm, den Film hätte ich jetzt gerne geshared. Und dann generiert er aus dieser Datei, aus diesem Film, das Torrent-File. Und das Torrent-File kann man wiederum dann irgendwo hochladen. Auf den eigenen Web-Server oder per E-Mail verschicken oder sonst was.
Aber heißt das nicht auch, dass du Leute auf deinen Rechner gucken lässt?
Die können nur drauf gucken, wenn sie da einen Torrent-File haben.
Die gucken ja nicht auf deinen Rechner, sondern die verbinden sich zu deinem BitTorrent-Client und laden dann diesen Film runter. Sonst sehen die genau nix.
Ach so, weil der Torrent-Client, also das Programm, was diese Torrents lesen und dekodieren kann, sozusagen nur ein Übersetzer der Datei ist, die irgendwo auf meinem Server liegt.
Der kümmert sich um die Arbeit. Der nimmt die Verbindung der anderen Teilnehmern entgegen, die auch an diesem Film interessiert sind, weil sie dieses Torrent-File bekommen haben, nimmt die Connections entgegen, guckt nach, was denen fehlt, falls es einer ist, der noch nicht alles hat, was ihm selber fehlt, um dann mit den anderen zu tauschen. Weil der, der anfängt, hat natürlich alles, weil der hat ja den Film. So, aber der erste connectet sich, lädt einen Teil davon runter, dann connectet der sich wieder zu einem weiteren und dann können die dieses erste Teil auch schon wieder miteinander tauschen.
Aber wir hatten ja am Anfang schon mal erwähnt, dass natürlich das Thema File Sharing sofort bei vielen, da geht die Antenne hoch von wegen, da werden illegal Daten getauscht, dann kommt die Staatsanwaltschaft und checkt da den Computer. Es werden ja noch andere Sachen getan.
Das ist schon erstmal richtig, dass natürlich die neuesten Technologien werden, dieser Bram Kohn, der ist so ein Übernerd, würde ich mal behaupten. Wenn der da anfängt, dann interessiert sich natürlich nicht Firmen wie IBM oder Blizzard, die halt WoW machen, also World of Warcraft oder Sun Solaris und so. Dann interessieren die sich natürlich nicht dafür, sondern dann sind die anderen Hacker ganz schnell dabei und es sind natürlich erstmal illegale Sachen, so geht es halt los. Das gleiche gilt übrigens fürs Pornbusiness, das ist einfach so, die sind mit dem Geldkassieren immer am schnellsten am Internet. Aber nach einer Weile merken sie halt, so schlecht ist es ja nicht. Und deswegen kommen die halt hier bei, also ich finde, das ist ja mal das beste Beispiel. Blizzard mit World of Warcraft, die mussten halt vor 3-4 Wochen diesen Patch für diese Erweiterung, für Level 80 irgendwie rauskriegen, das war 1, 6 Gigabyte groß, also nur das Update zu dem Spiel. Und das musste halt innerhalb von 3-4 Wochen an irgendwie die 10 Millionen Spieler verteilt werden.
Wenn die sich alle auf einen Link drauf gestürzt hätten, dann hätte der Server in die Handy geklatscht, hätte ich gesagt, ich fahre an Urlaub.
Gibt es auch Services für, wie man das weltweit regeln kann, aber Blizzard war halt ein bisschen schlauer, die haben sich gedacht, machen wir doch mit BitTorrent. Das hatten sie sich vor drei, vier Jahren schon gedacht. Ist halt billiger und ist auch irgendwie die Zukunft. Und sie haben aufs richtige Pferdchen gesetzt. Und das flutscht wie nix. Weil Spieler A, der es runterlädt und schon zur Hälfte hat, kann selber schon teilweise an Spieler B, Spieler C, Spieler D schicken. Und alles, was ein Spieler an andere Spieler, also von World of Warcraft irgendwie, schickt, muss halt Blizzard irgendwie nicht an Daten rausschicken. Und die müssen ja am Ende für die Daten bezahlen, auch wenn die bestimmt einen guten Preis kriegen bei der Menge. Aber sparen tun sie dann trotzdem.
Du hast gerade gesagt, die Anfänge bei solcher Technologie wären natürlich gerne genutzt oder schnell genutzt, um illegale Sachen zu verbreiten. Wie ist denn das jetzt mit diesen Listen von Usern von Kazaa, Limeware und wie sie alle hießen, die dann bei Staatsanwaltschaften gelandet sind, wo dann Leute verklagt wurden, weil sie irgendwie einen ganzen raumvoll Musiker, den sie verteilt haben? Ist es bei BitTorrent anders?
Nee. Weil den Teil, den wir bisher noch komplett außen vor gelassen haben, ist, dass diese Leute, die an der Datei interessiert sind, sich natürlich irgendwie gegenseitig finden müssen. Dazu steht in der Torrent-Datei nämlich noch ein Adressedribbel von einem Server, dem sogenannten Tracker. Und bei diesem Tracker, der funktioniert wie eine Mitfahrtzentrale. Da sagt man, ich hab da diese Datei, die erkennst du an diesem Fingerprint, an dieser Checksumme. Und ich würde diese gerne tauschen. Und wenn jemand anderes vorbeikommt und nach derselben Datei fragt, dann gib ihm mal meine Adresse. Und sag mal, ob du da auch schon welche gespeichert hast, die vorher da gewesen sind. Und natürlich sammeln sich dann bei diesen Trackern die Adressen der Leute, die diese Dateien getauscht haben, an. Und die Staatsanwaltschaften, da sagen wir so, die rechte Inhaber an die Dateien, können natürlich auch wieder in dieselben Torrents reingucken. Und können dann den Tracker genauso fragen, wer dann noch diese Datei herunterlädt und sich dann dafür interessiert. Also es ist keineswegs so, dass man da jetzt als über BitTorrent anonym unterwegs wäre oder dass es nicht möglich wäre, rauszufinden, wer jetzt die Dateien herunterlädt.
Also solltet ihr euch mit unanständigen Gedanken tragen, vergesst es gleich wieder, BitTorrent zu nutzen. Ihr werdet euch genauso die Finger verbrennen, wie bei allen anderen Sachen auch. Wir haben den nächsten Anrufer bei uns an der Leitung unter 0331 70 97 110. Zur Frage, wie habt ihr denn eigentlich die ersten Daten getauscht? Die geht jetzt an Axel aus Berlin. Hallo Axel. Krügs und Erdgeist. Oh, Dennis ist auch hier. Axel, wir hatten ja gerade die Geschichte mit dem Akustikwandler und mit diesem Ding, was man auf den Fernseher kleben musste, um sich das Bild zu ziehen.
Nicht übel, ja. Also die ersten Varianten bei uns waren tatsächlich noch lochstreifen.
Du bist älter als 39.
Ich bin älter als 39. Wieso? Dann hat Kajetan die falsche Zahl drauf geschrieben. 43. Aber egal.
Tut jetzt auch nichts zur Sache?
Es tut jetzt gar nichts zur Sache. Lochstreifen für alle, die es vielleicht gar nicht mehr kennen, sind lange Papierstreifen. Mit Löchern. Und zwar die Kodierung. Sprich, das, was sie eigentlich tauschen will, ist die Einfachung der Löcher an einer bestimmten Stelle. Es gab verschiedene Codes. Im Endeffekt wurden bis zu acht Löcher in einer Spalte. Und die haben dann die Bits kodiert. Und auf die Art und Weise konnte man dann Programme von einem kompatiblen Leser zum anderen transportieren.
Dann hast du unterwegs, wenn du mit jemanden die Dateien tauschen wolltest, du warst mal mit einem Locher unterwegs und hast dann geguckt...
Nein, das natürlich nicht. Ich hatte auch so ein Ding nicht privat. Die waren wohl auch noch ein bisschen sehr abartig teuer. Wir hatten an der Uni halt mehrere Varianten. Eine davon war halt Lochstreifenleser. Die andere Variante, die dann eigentlich noch älter war, die ich aber selber später beim Wickel hatte, waren also Lochkarten. Wo man sich ungefähr vorstellen muss, ein Befehl auf einer Karte. Das heißt, die Kartenstapel für längere Programme waren schon sehr hoch und es war hohe Kunst, die richtig zu transportieren, weil...
Ohne, dass sie durcheinander kommen.
Weil wenn der Kartenstapel runterfällt, hat man richtig einen Hauptgewinn. Die Kartenleser haben nämlich noch nicht mal die Befehle drauf gedruckt, sondern die haben wirklich nur die Dinger gelocht und dann durfte man selber anfangen zu lesen, was auf der Karte steht.
Okay, das sind die Geschichten aus der Anfang zur Mittelfase des letzten Jahrtausends. Wie arbeitest du denn heute?
Na ja, sozusagen dank, sagen wir mal, auf Arbeitmitglied im deutschen Forschungsnetz steht die Frage der Netzwerkanbindung eigentlich nicht mehr so richtig, sondern die schnellste Anbindung ist irgendwo an der Stelle, oder besser der Flaschenhalt ist irgendwo an der Stelle zu meinem Rechner. Alles andere nach draußen, was innerhalb der Universitäten, sagen wir mal, Deutschland vielleicht noch besser Forschungseinrichtungen europaweit geht, ist nicht die Frage der Übertragung.
Okay, Axel, vielen Dank für diese kurzen Einblicke in die ganz, ganz, ganz frühen Anfänge des Datenaustausches. Lochkarten gab es auch mal vor einer ganzen Weile. Danke dir für den Anruf und schönen Abend noch.
Ja, euch auch.
Und wir machen hier im Chaosradio gleich weiter nach den Nachrichten mit euch unter 0331 70 97 110. Datenaustausch im Jahr 2008 ist das Thema. Wir sind bei BitTorrent System und werden da noch tiefer einsteigen.
Siehst du mich? Gleichzeitig freu ich mich von dem gesunkenen Gefühl, dass wir nicht existieren, bis zum Weg, in dem wir Missen-Messagen sind. Es ist schwer zu erlauben, aber du kannst nicht verweigen, du kannst nicht glauben, was du mit deinen eigenen Augen siehst.
Gestern Abend noch in Berlin im Lido. Jetzt zu hören im Chaosradio auf Fritz Mocky und Jamie Liddell.
Der November ist der natürliche Fressfeind der guten Laune. Aber eine ganz besondere Party mit ganz besonderen DJs ist der natürliche Fressfeind des Novembers. Das Fistful Party Festival. Zwei Nächte auf vier Floors. Mit ganz besonderen DJs, die sonst eigentlich nur mit ganz besonderen Bands unterwegs sind.
DJ Luke von Sea.
Armin und Thorsten von den BeatStakes. DJ Kraft von KIZ. Und das sind links noch nicht alle. Wir haben die ganz besonderen DJs. Ihr die ganz besondere Party.
Zwei Nächte auf vier Floors.
Das Fritztop Party Festival, kommenden Freitag und Samstag. Im Fritztop, im Postbahnhof. Direkt am Berliner Ostbahnhof. Und dann soll er mal sehen, was er davon hat. Der November. Und das hört man.
22 32. Mit Keitantürlich.
Bei Anschlägen und Schießereien in der indischen Stadt Bombay sind mindestens 78 Menschen getötet und 200 verletzt worden. Das gab die indische Polizei bekannt. Mindestens sieben Orte seien angegriffen worden. Unter anderem zwei Luxushotels und ein Touristencafé. Die Attentäter hätten wahllos in die Menge gefeuert. An einigen Orten hätten die Täter auch Handgranaten geworfen. Wer hinter dem Anschlag steckt, ist noch nicht klar. Die indische Polizei spricht von einem Terroranschlag. Ob unter den Opfern auch Deutsche sind, will das Auswärtige Amt noch am Abend klären. In diesem Wintersemester gibt es offenbar so viele Studienanfänger wie noch nie. Die Wochenzeitung Die Zeit hat ausgerechnet, dass sich 334.000 junge Leute neu eingeschrieben haben. Das sind gut 6% mehr als im letzten Jahr. Demnach haben vor allem das Saarland Hessen und Hamburg bei den Studienanfängern zugelegt. Aber auch in Brandenburg gab es einen Studentenansturm. Die Zahlen will das Statistische Bundesamt am Montag offiziell rausgeben. Nur jeder dritte junge Hartz IV-Empfänger schafft offenbar den Ausstieg aus der Arbeitslosigkeit. Das zeigen Zahlen aus den letzten Jahren der Bundesagentur für Arbeit. Besonders gefährdet sind dennach Leute mit schlechter Ausbildung. Wer schon während der Schulzeit auf Arbeitslosengeld II angewiesen ist, hat laut der Studie auch kaum Möglichkeiten, sich später weiterzuentwickeln. In Thailand halten Regierungsgänger weiter den Flughafen in Bangkok besetzt. Hunderte Deutsche sitzen in der thailändischen Hauptstadt fest. Die meisten Fluggesellschaften haben ihre Flüge gestrichen. Einige leiten ihre Maschinen um. Das Auswärtige Amt empfiehlt, den Flughafen von Bangkok vorerst zu meiden. Regierungsgänger werfen Ministerpräsident Somchai unter anderem Korruption vor und verlangen seinen Rücktritt. In der Fußball Champions League spielt Werder Bremen gerade in Zypern bei Anautosis Famagusta. Kurz zu Ende des Spiels liegen die Bremer mit 2 zu 1 hinten. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen heute Abend in Frankfurt und Cottbus haben wir 3 Grad, Potsdam und Angermünde 4, Neuropin 5, Wittenberge 6 und in Berlin 5 Grad. Im Vergleich zu den letzten Tagen ist es heute Abend schon fast tropisch warm draußen, mit Tiesstärten von gerade mal 2 Grad. Allerdings gibt es in einigen Gegenden immer wieder Regen oder Sprühregen. Morgen dann ist es ziemlich bewölkt, vor allem im Norden kann es etwas regnen, in Richtung Süden kommt auch mal die Sonne raus, das Ganze dann bei maximal 7 Grad. Mit einer Meldung aus dem Stadtverkehr Berlin auf der A100 Stadtrinkrichtung Wedding zwischen dem Spandauer Damm und dem Siemens Damm, da gibt es 1 Kilometer Stau. Ansonsten, allen die unterwegs sind, eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 1, dann Fritz in der Prägnitz.
Morgen Geist, Richard, am Chaos Radio Fritz, Teil 141 am 26. November 2008. Der Chaos Computer Club ist hier Dennis Krögs und Erdgeist. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Ihr seid eingeladen mitzumachen, mitzudiskutieren und anzurufen unter der 0331 70 97 110. Das Thema der heutigen Sendung ist BitTorrent. Wir haben ja ganz kurz im Vorfeld schonmal angefangen, die Geschichte aufzuräufeln, wie das mit dem Austausch von Daten eigentlich mal war. Wir hatten das Stichwort Lochkarten, was hier unter anderem auch fiel. Dann gab es die Geschichte, ich habe etwas, was du haben möchtest. Es gibt also einen Link, du saugst dir das runter und fertig. Das dauert unglaublich lange und wenn viele Leute das haben wollen, dann bricht das komplette System zusammen. Dann kamen wir zu den P2P-Programm wie Nutella oder LimeWire, die aber auch etliche Nachteile hatten und sind jetzt beim Torrent-System angekommen. Erdgeist, lass uns das nochmal ganz kurz an einem praktischen Beispiel auseinanderdröseln, wie sowas funktioniert. Also, ich hab einen Film gedreht, was weiß ich, letzte Woche Party, Sportfest, keine Ahnung, irgendwas. Und möchte den jetzt ins Netz stellen, dass sich alle Leute den ziehen können. Und du vermeide jetzt mal YouTube und diesen ganzen Krempel.
Du willst da alle eins Mitglieder, die auf der Party gewesen sind, auch an diese Datei rankommen. Du hast bei dir zu Hause noch eine alte ESD-Strecke.
Und jetzt ist es ein verdammt großer Verein, sodass das natürlich nicht über normalen Link funktionieren würde.
Jetzt besorgst du dir so ein BitTorrent-Programm. Und dieses BitTorrent-Programm betrachtet diesen Film so als großes Puzzle. Und zerlegt halt den Film in einzelne Puzzleteile.
Diese BitTorrent-Programme sind Freeware, die gibt es also im Netz.
Ich glaube, gibt es irgendeinen, wo man den Film bezahlen muss, Dennis?
Wie viele gibt es denn da, über die Schätzung? 5, 10, 3000?
Na so ein Dutzend so bekannte, bestimmt noch ganz viele so Kleinkramen.
Ist das egal, welche verwendet wird?
Ja, die müssen sich alle an den BitTorrent-Standard halten, mehr oder weniger. Da gibt es auch so einzelne Erweiterungen, aber im Großen und Ganzen sind die schon kompatibel alle.
Also ich entscheide danach, welches am besten aussieht und welche ich am einfachsten bedienen kann. Und halt mir gesaugt, jetzt.
Hast du dir gesaugt, jetzt sagst du, da nimm die Datei, der guckt sich die an, wie gesagt, zerteilt die, wie muss man sich vorstellen, wie so ein Puzzle und guckt sich jedes einzelne Puzzle-Teil an und guckt sich da so grobe Beschreibung an. So irgendwie links oben, da ist so ein bisschen mehr rot und irgendwie so, das andere ist ein bisschen andere Farbe und schreibt das irgendwie in so eine Datei zusammen.
Also ähnlich wie ein Fernsehbild auseinandergenommen wird, mit unterschiedlichen Punkten.
Na, doch schon ein bisschen grober.
Jetzt Sendung mit der Maus, was?
Sendung mit der Maus. Naja, so ein paar Kilobyte aus der Datei werden dann als Puzzle steinweiseite gelegt, die natürlich du hast und die am Ende auch alle anderen wieder wollen. Und über diese paar Kilobyte kann man so Aussagen treffen, die sich dann, wenn es angekommen ist, wieder überprüfen lassen.
Okay, also habe ich jetzt den Torrent-Klein, der prökelt das Ding auseinander.
Genau, dann musst du ihm noch eine Adresse von einem der vielen offenen Trecker sagen. Trecker war diese Mitfahrtzentrale, erinnern wir uns. Und das treckst du da auch noch in die Torrent-Datei ein.
Dann zählst du einen aus und dann gibt es ganz viele verschiedene Trecker und du suchst einfach den aus, den du meinst, der super ist.
Genau, du kannst auch mehrere eintragen, inzwischen sind die glaube ich alle offen. Und dann bist du eigentlich fertig. Dann hast du diese kleine Torrent-Datei erzeugt und die kann jetzt zu deinen Freunden. Da kannst du dir entweder, wenn sie ein bisschen öffentlicher ist, dann tust du sie auf eine von den Suchseiten, da wie PirateBay zum Beispiel. Genau.
Oder auf die Diskette und bringst sie dann per Diskette mit.
Ja, weil der Film würde nicht auf die Diskette passen.
Genau, und kannst du dann alle in die Hand drücken. Und die machen auf der anderen Seite dasselbe. Die starten sich auch ein heruntergeladenes Torrent-Programm und dann werfen sie da dieses Torrent dagegen. Und was der Torrent kleint dann macht, ist sich mit diesem Tracker auch verbinden und Bescheid sagen, da hat mir jemand so eine Datei gegeben mit diesem Film, den ich jetzt runterladen möchte. Sag mir doch mal, wo kann ich ihn überall herbekommen? Und wenn er Glück hat und nicht der Erste ist, dann war da schon vorher jemand beim Tracker gewesen und holt sich jetzt die Adressen von allen anderen. Wahrscheinlich der, und zwar du. Du warst als allererstes dann bei dem Tracker und hast gesagt, ich hab da die Datei und wenn jemand danach fragt, dann gib ihm mal meine Adresse. Und dein Vereinskamerad, der würde dann jetzt anfangen und würde sich wahrscheinlich zu dir verbinden und den ersten Block runterladen. Also das erste Puzzleteil. Man würde dann, weil er weiß, wie groß und breit der Puzzle ist, würde er das dann an die richtige Stelle schon mal hinlegen und wenn er damit fertig ist, dann würde er den zweiten haben.
Und da der, da das Programm, also der, der Torrent-Client weiß ja, wie groß die Datei insgesamt ist und um die es geht, weil es steht ja drin. Und wo welches Puzzle-Feier liegt, kann er mir dann etwa sagen, du bleibst jetzt hier sitzen, ist gleich fertig oder aber du kommst in 14 Tagen wieder.
Genau, der weiß, das sind irgendwie 500 Puzzle-Stückchen, eins hat er schon, das kommt so und so schnell rein, also ist es ungefähr in 5 Stunden fertig.
Was ist denn jetzt?
Das ist aber noch nicht der spannende Teil, weil jetzt ist er halt noch so wie es bisher war, so von wegen einer bietet es an und der andere will es dann haben. Viel spannender wird es jetzt, wenn noch der Vereinschef daherkommt und der will das auch. Der verbindet sich dann auch mit seinem frischer runtergeladenen Torrent-Programm bei dem Trecker wieder und bekommt dann die Adresse von dir und dem anderen Vereinskameraden.
Der kriegt schon zwei Adressen, genau.
Und dann kann er sich zu beiden verbinden und sagt, ich hab da gerade 0% von der Datei, aber du hast da alles und der andere hatte den ersten Block, dann gib du mal wo du den ersten Block hast, gib mir mal den ersten Block und der, also Ju, würdest ihm dann den zweiten Block geben.
Das klingt, als ob es dann irgendwann fürchterlich im Schneeballsystem Chaos endet.
Genau, die fangen auch nicht mal bei eins an, sondern die machen das random, damit jeder möglichst immer irgendwas holt, was ein anderer noch nicht hat. Also damit nicht alle, wenn jetzt alle kommen und wieder alle den ersten Teil haben wollen, dann sind wir ja da, wo wir früher auch waren, dann sind alle wieder gleich. Dann können sie auch danach nichts tauschen, weil dann hat ja jeder den ersten. Das heißt, einer muss irgendwie den 17. holen, einer den 35. einer den 42. und einer den 23. Und dann können die untereinander auch tauschen, weil keiner hat irgendwie das, was der andere auch schon hat. Das kommt dann erst später, aber dann können sie sozusagen gleichmäßig irgendwie runterladen.
Das Ziel ist, so schnell wie möglich alle Puzzlestücke an alle verteilt zu haben, sodass alle Puzzlestücke da draußen mindestens einmal vorhanden sind.
Okay, aber wenn es so einfach wäre und so eine geniale Lösung, dann würde nicht so ein großes Halb-Boot rumgemacht werden, sondern sie wäre auf jedem Rechner schon vorinstalliert, den ich kaufen kann beim Kaffeeladen um die Ecke.
Na, es ist nicht ganz so einfach, weil du brauchst ja immer noch diesen Trecker und du musst ja erst mal diese Datei erstellen. Haben auch schon viele nachgedacht, dass man irgendwie BitTorrent, ich glaube bei Opera, dieser Browser, den gibt es ja, da ist glaube ich das BitTorrent-Protokoll inzwischen mit in den Browser eingebaut. Also die denken da schon ein bisschen drüber nach. Ich weiß nicht, ob es auch irgendwann mal in einem Betriebssystem landet, wieso nicht? Also Updates zum Beispiel, wenn irgendwie Microsoft ja in den Milliarden von Usern irgendwie Milliarden von Megabytes ausliefern muss, alles gleichzeitig, weil irgendwie die Sicherheit der Welt ist bedroht, wegen irgendwie kein Rechner würde mehr gehen. Sonst irgendwie, dann müssen halt ihre Patches raustun und das wäre auch vielleicht über BitTorrent und da ist ja signiertes. Also durch diese Prüfung, die in diesem Torrent-File stecken, kann man ja auch sicherstellen, dass der Inhalt korrekt ist, den man da bekommt, könnte man das auch in ein Betriebssystem integrieren.
Um an das Beispiel zurückzukommen mit dem Film, den wir jetzt in unterschiedlichen Blöcke auseinanderprökeln und jeder schickt einen dieser vielen Blöcke an irgendjemand anders und irgendwann kommt auf der anderen Seite wieder der endgültige Film zu Ende.
Nicht nur auf der anderen Seite, sondern auf allen anderen.
Überall, genau, kommt der endgültige Film raus, weil der Torrent-Programm ja den wieder so zusammensetzt, wie es sein muss. Dann ist doch eigentlich der Engpass, wenn plötzlich mehrere Leute den Stecker ziehen und sagen, ich bin aus diesem Netz raus.
Ja, erst mal schon.
Nicht unbedingt, man könnte jetzt sogar sagen, dass du hast ja angefangen mit dem Film, du warst ja der Erste und noch keiner hat den Film komplett runtergeladen. Und du sagst, ich hab jetzt keinen Bock mehr, Laptop zu, ich geh ins Bett. So, zack, ist der weg, der den ganzen Film hatte. So, aber erst mal fangen die an untereinander das zu tauschen, damit jeder erst mal auf den gleichen Stand kommt. So, und wenn jetzt sagen wir mal, wir machen es mit den Puzzlen, wir machen jetzt ein bisschen weniger Puzzle. Wir machen jetzt, der Film besteht nur aus zwei Puzzlen, um es mal zu vereinfachen. Der eine hat die eine Hälfte, der andere hat die andere Hälfte. Dann haben sie zwar beide nicht den gesamten Film, aber jeder Einzelne, wenn man sie zusammenfügt, schon. Und wenn die sich dann untereinander austauschen und alle Teile sind irgendwo vorhanden, dann können die das noch miteinander regeln und sich das verteilen. Und dann hat irgendwann jemand den ganzen, da musst du gar nicht mehr mit deinem gesamten Film da sein. Hauptsache, jedes Stück, jedes Puzzle ist einmal noch irgendwo in diesem Schwarm, nennt man das vorhanden oder in dieser Wolke. Und dann geht's.
Okay, aber die Sendung mit der Mausfrage wäre jetzt wieder, wenn das Original meins noch nicht komplett verteilt ist. Wenn ihr alle erstmal Stöchchen davon habt.
Wenn du nur ein einziges Teil noch nicht rausgeschoben hast, dann geht's natürlich nicht. Dann müssen die bis nächsten Morgen warten, bis du wieder aufstehst, dein Rechner wieder aufmachst. Dann sagen die hier uns fehlt noch dieses eine Puzzlestück, dein Rechner schiebt das raus und bupp sind sie alle fertig.
Gibt es da Bestrebungen, dieses Prinzip irgendwie noch zu verbessern, zu vereinfachen, dass dieser Engpass eben nicht mehr stattfindet? Das würde ja eigentlich bedeuten, dass...
Einmal rausschicken musst du's ja, weil das geht ja irgendwie nicht anders. Aber es gibt natürlich Bestrebungen, es ist aber auch schon wieder ein paar Jahre alt, dass man jedes Teil halt möglichst nur einmal rausschickt und nicht mehrmals. Weil wenn jetzt, sagen wir mal, du hast 1000 Vereinskollegen und sind aber trotzdem immer vier, fünf, sechs, sieben Leute, die das gleiche Puzzle von dir anfordern, dann musst du's ja fünf, sechs, sieben Mal rausschicken. Das ist ja schon Verschwendung. Und deswegen hat sich so ein Typ mal so eine Erweiterung einfallen lassen, ist jetzt ein bisschen technisch, aber er erzählt mal kurz, ist der Super Seat Mode, der sorgt dafür, dass jedes Teil irgendwie nur einmal rausgeschoben wird. Und das hat gebracht, dass es, der hat es halt prozentual ausgedrückt, dass man als erster Seeder, so nennt man das halt mit diesem Film, du halt, dass du es nicht drei bis vier Mal ungefähr an 100 Leute verschicken musst, damit sie draußen sind, sondern nur noch circa zehn Prozent mehr als der Film eigentlich groß ist. Also heißt nur zehn Prozent zu viel versendet. Und vorher war es halt irgendwie drei, vierhundert Prozent. Und das ist schon besser. Also wer es mal wissen will, soll sich diesen Super Seat Mode angucken und dann geht es ein bisschen flotter.
Chaosradio.ccc.de ist die Webseite zur Sendung und auch zum Chaos Computer Club. Und da gibt es auch ein Wiki, wo Fragen gestellt werden können, die hier auch auftauchen. Eine der meist gestellten Fragen war, was ist denn jetzt dieses File Sharing Tool, was zu empfehlen ist? Wollt ihr dann ein Ranking rausgeben?
Ja, wir können ja unsere eigenen Präferenzen irgendwie rausgeben. Also ich bin hier bunt die Clicky Nutzer und benutze deswegen den Transmission Client. Den gibt es aber inzwischen nicht nur für Mac, sondern auch für Linux und FreeBSD und als Command Line Version und sogar als WebClick Version irgendwie mit so einem Demon dahinter. Also der ist irgendwie ziemlich umfangreich und flutscht. Und das, was ich nicht nehmen würde, kann ich ja auch gleich sagen, das ist der ehemalige Azurius in Java geschrieben. Und der nennt sich jetzt Fuse, glaube ich. V-U-Z-E, wie auch immer man das ausspricht. Aber ich glaube, es ist Fuse. Und der ist irgendwie der 1000 Milliarden Features, aber es soll überladen, ich blicke da irgendwie nicht durch. Und weil er in Java ist oder weil er einfach schlecht programmiert ist, keine Ahnung, flutscht der irgendwie auch nicht.
Okay, also...
Kann aber eine Menge wohl.
Transmission ganz vorne.
Ja, auch Transmission.
Also ich benutze auf meinem Desktop Transmission, ansonsten AirTorrent.
Dann können wir noch ein paar andere. Es gibt noch Mikrotorrent, das ist der von dem Bram Cohn. Der hat halt irgendwann mal eine Firma gegründet, die heißt bittorrent.com. Und die haben halt einen freien gekauft nach einer Weile, weil der Source-Good von dem selbst war früher ein Python, aber dann haben sie halt dieses Mikrotorrent gekauft. Dann, wie gesagt, dieses Azurius und Ertorrent und Car-Torrent und was weiß ich, auf dem Mac gab's auch noch Bits of Wheels und Tomato oder irgendwie sowas und ach, Tausende.
Also es gibt die unterschiedlichsten Varianten. Einfach mal BitTorrent-Client in die Suchmaschine, eures größten Vertrauens reinhemmern und gucken. Was dann dabei rauskommt. Jetzt haben wir ganz kurz beschrieben, wie dieses System funktioniert. Gibt's denn da einen erklärten Vorteil gegenüber dem Filesharing-Programm, die es bislang gab? Also die LimeWire, Scars, Nutella dieser Welt?
Ich weiß nicht, ich würde einfach in die Statistik gucken, denn dann wüsste ich, dass da was dran sein muss. Also wie war das? Über 50 Prozent des weltweiten Traffics im Internet werden gerade von BitTorrent verursacht. Irgendetwas müssen sie richtig machen. Und ansonsten ist die Idee auch so simpel und einleuchtend, dass da einfach nicht mehr viel zu erklären ist, warum es einfach kaum besser geht.
Also bei den Protokollen vorher, Nutella und E-Donkey, gab es ja später sogenannte Masternodes oder Master-Server, die auch immer in Holland standen. Die wurden immer größer und immer fetter. Und irgendwann, weil auch viel illegaler Shit da drauf lag, wurden die von der Polizei einkassiert oder von wem auch immer oder dichtgemacht oder vom Provider gesperrt. Und dann war halt der Masternode weg und dann war das ganze Protokolle zusammengebrochen und damit das ganze Netzwerk. Und das geht bei BitTorrent nicht, weil BitTorrent ist total unabhängig, wenn die einen Trecker, der nur illegalen Scheiß macht, wenn der gesperrt wird, dann kommt irgendwo ein neuer. Und auch die Firmen, die da keinen illegalen Scheiß machen wollen, sondern wie Blizzard, Solaris und so weiter, die haben halt einfach ihre eigenen legalen Trecker und dann benutzt man die, also es ist unabhängig voneinander. Und deswegen geht es auch mit diesem, dass man sagt, das ist ja nur illegales Zeug und es ist alles böse und so, das kann man so nicht sagen, weil es gibt so eine und so eine Trecker.
Da wäre es ganz interessant, auf den Fakt noch mal einzugehen, dass es nicht nur für sozusagen die private Nutzung von Daten hauptsächlich da ist. Wir haben ja, lassen wir uns mal bei diesem Bild bleiben, von dem Film vom letzten Sportfest, der geteilt wird, sondern dass auch viele große Firmen und kommerzielle Anbieter mittlerweile BitTorrent nutzen, um Daten rauszugeben, Blizzard und World of Warcraft haben wir gerade erwähnt, die das neue Patch per Torrent rausgegeben haben. Gibt es da noch mehr? Wird das größer? Gibt es da auch viele Entwicklungen?
Auf unserem Vorbereitungstitel hatte ich noch diese Postgres-Datenbank und da haben wir letztens mal geguckt, die haben das eingestellt, weil ihnen der Aufwand zu hoch war. Also BitTorrent ist natürlich nicht viel Aufwand, aber die Datenbank ist mit 10 MB, 10 MB sind heutzutage gar nichts mehr. Da haben die gesagt, das lohnt es ja einfach nicht. Die Leute sollen klicken und unseren Web-Server irgendwie behämmern und der kann das ausliefern und das ist kein Problem mehr. Aber alles, was ein bisschen größer ist, lohnt sich natürlich schon. FreeBSD macht das, die haben irgendwie ihre DVD oder CD-Images, also mindestens 700 MB und ich weiß nicht, alle paar Monate oder Snapshots kommen da irgendwie alle paar Wochen ein neues und dann verteilen sie es so ein bisschen schneller. Open Solaris macht das.
Lieblingsdistributionen machen das auch alle. Die benutzen auch alle inzwischen BitTorrent, um ihre ISO-Dateien zu verteilen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob es inzwischen schon so Setupbox-Leute gibt, die BitTorrent benutzen.
Um die Frage noch mal andersherum zu stellen, welche Ausbaumöglichkeiten hat BitTorrent, die auch früher oder später kommerziell genutzt werden, weil alle Firmen, die mit großen Datenmengen umgehen, finden das System natürlich geil?
Zum Beispiel die Setupboxen, wie ich gerade sagte. Die Idee wäre, dass man sich eine Setupbox zu Hause instellt, wie man es jetzt auch schon macht. Und dass die einfach über den DSL-Anschluss BitTorrent macht. Also auf dieser Setupbox läuft ein BitTorrent-Client, den man selber nicht kontrolliert. Also nicht so wirklich, über das Web oder die Fernbedienung bedienen. Und der Kabelnetzbetreiber oder der Setupbox-Anbieter, der spielt dann sozusagen nebenbei dort neue Filme drauf. Und die kann man dann anklicken, sobald sie fertig sind. Das wäre so eine legale Anwendung, die demnächst bestimmt kommen wird.
Gibt es da schon konkretere Entwicklungen?
Ja, da baut BitTorrent, kommt baut gerade daran, auch das BitTorrent-Protokoll noch ein bisschen so umzubauen. Weil, wie Dennis erzählte, dass bisher der Film so zusammengestückelt wird, dass viele Leute wirklich random, also Zufallspositionen, in den Puzzle bekommen. Aber wenn man einen Film gucken möchte, eigentlich den Film ja von Anfang an guckt, üblicherweise.
Im Normalfall schon.
Bis jetzt müsste man warten, bis er komplett da ist. Und das ist natürlich doof. Man will eigentlich anfangen, bevor der Film komplett runtergeladen ist. Also muss man den Leuten die anfänglichen Puzzlestücke geben, sodass sie anfangen können, schon mal den Film zu gucken.
Also bist du auch wieder in einer Warteposition. Es ist nicht hingehen, Rechner anmachen, sagen haben wollen und nach fünf Minuten loslegen.
Fünf Minuten ist doch schon die Zeit, in der man so vielleicht eine Serie, die gestern angelaufen ist, auf seinem Rechner haben kann. Also nach fünf Minuten ist schon drin. Und mit dieser Erweiterung, dass die Vorlastblöcke zuerst kommen, da wollte ja BitTorrent kommen, dann auch wirklich Geld mitverdienen.
Denen geht es noch nicht gut. Aber kurze Frage, wenn wieder alle von vorne laden, wie ist es denn mit der gleichmäßigen Verteilung? Also wenn alle nur Block eins laden, dann können die ja untereinander nicht tauschen. Das haben sie ja alle Block eins.
Aber es können nicht alle der erste Block sein. Das kannst du ja sagen, die ersten 20 Prozent verteilen wir erstmal.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Es gibt genug Leute, die irgendwie gerade genau so machen.
Außerdem hat ja einer eine Stunde vorher angefangen mit seinem Film und einer eine Stunde später und dann verteilt sich das wieder.
Also wäre das eine Nutzungsmöglichkeit für Film, Musik, Video und Demand, wie auch immer, das in Zukunft zu verwenden wäre? Wie groß ist denn der technische Aufwand, so was zu bauen? Wie groß wäre denn so eine Topkiste?
Gar nicht groß.
Ich sehe jetzt zuhause Leute mit Laubsäge und Lötkolben, die lassen das in der Kugelbohrung.
Nein, nein, ein Setupbox ist halt so ein normaler Plastikasten, wie man ihn sich heutzutage auch schon hinstellt. Man könnte statt der Setupbox auch den WLAN-Router nehmen, den man zuhause hat, wenn der genug Festplattenplatz hat. Dann kann da ein BitTorrent-Client drauflaufen, der Dateinrouter laden kann. Also es könnte vom WLAN-Access-Point bis zum DSL-Router bis zum TiVo mit BitTorrent-Client, könnte das alles sein.
Also ist BitTorrent, hat BitTorrent die Kapazitäten, alles andere, was bislang da war, abzulösen?
Na, BitTorrent hat auch Nachteile. Also BitTorrent hat zum Beispiel den Nachteil, wenn du irgendwas suchst, was von vor drei Monaten oder von vor drei Jahren ist, hast du eigentlich keine Chance mehr. BitTorrent ist dafür, dass man Daten, die jetzt viele Leute haben möchten, schnell verteilen kann. Ist nicht dazu da, irgendwas zu archivieren oder...
Also schon mit deinem Sportverein, wenn du das irgendwie zwei Wochen schiebst, du deinen Film raus und denkst, jetzt reicht es mal, es hat auch irgendwie andere Sachen zu tun, oder ein neuer Film kommt und dann bietest du den alten nicht mehr an und deine ganzen Vereinskollegen halt auch nicht mehr und dann kommt aber der neue Vereinskollege und will diesen alten Film haben, dann startet er und dann ist keiner mehr da. Dann müsste mindestens einem von euch Bescheid sagen, dass er nochmal startet, dass das nochmal angeboten wird, weil wenn keiner da ist, kann er auch nicht runterladen. Und die trocknen sozusagen aus, die Torrent-Pfals. Da ist keiner mehr da, der es hat.
Also bei Setup-Boxen ist das nicht so das Problem, weil meistens wollen die Leute ja frischen Inhalt sehen. Die wollen ja meistens nicht die uralten Filme von vor 70 Jahren sehen, sondern die neuen Serien, die gerade rausgekommen sind und die wollen alle haben und da dementsprechend gut funktioniert in dem Fall dann auch BitTorrent. Und für die alten Sachen können sich die Setup-Box-Firmen ja immer noch Server hinstellen, die es trotzdem mal wissen verteilen. Es dauert dann ein bisschen länger, aber es würde gehen.
Klingt jetzt wie eine Autowerbung. Ist einfach, kostnüchst, geht ganz schnell, ratz-batz, alles super. Der einzige Fragezeichen, was in der letzten halben Stunde immer noch wieder auftaucht, ist dieser ominöse Tracker, wo du sagst, ja, muss man den Tracker erstmal besorgen.
Dann nicht besorgen, sondern man muss die Adresse kennen. Du musst irgendwo eine freie Trackeradresse rausfinden. Oder zum Beispiel, um es mal ganz einfach zu machen, man nimmt eine von den PirateBay-Trackeradressen, weil die sind frei, da kann sich jeder, jeder kann, also anmelden ist das falsche Wort, sondern man trägt einfach die Adresse beim Torrent erstellen ein und ist die Adresse des Trackers da drin.
Dann lass doch wie bei der Mitfahrtzentrale bleiben. Das ist einfach so, du weißt in deiner Stadt, die Adresse von den vier Mitfahrtzentralen, die es da gibt. Und genauso, wenn du kurz im Netz nachguckst, findest du auch die Adressen von den Mitfahrtzentralen für die Torrents. Und dann gehst du einfach dahin, hängst dein Schild hin, musst dich nicht vorher anmelden, sondern sagst, wer will mitfahren. Ganz einfach. Aber wir haben noch was vergessen. Bei den wirklich groß getauschten Dateien über BitTorrent, der Chaos Computer Club, verteilt seine Aufnahmen von den Kongressen und Cams von den Vorträgen eigentlich auch schon seit, glaube ich, drei Jahren über BitTorrent. Und wir bieten die, glaube ich, auch noch von vor ewig mit an.
Ja, wenn die noch jemand sieht, weiß er nicht. So könnte auch sein, dass die ausgetrocknet sind tun wir. Ich hab schon lange nicht mehr geguckt, muss ich zugeben.
Genau. Ihr könnt nämlich von all unseren Kongressen euch noch die Videos angucken und die euch über BitTorrent runterladen.
Das heißt, ihr umgeht damit das eben angesprochene Problem, dass so ein Seed irgendwann austrocknet, weil keiner die, also weil alle Leute nur die aktuellen Sachen haben wollen, dass ihr so gutherzig, so offiziell seid, dass ihr alles rausschiebt, was jemals immer da war.
Da ist ja dann am Ende, wollen ja die alten Sachen, wollen ja wenig Leute haben, dann macht das auch nicht so viel Last da.
Ist ja nicht schlimm, was anzubieten, was keiner will, weil dann muss der Kleintes ja auch nicht rausschieben. Also es ist nur, falls einer kommen würde. Es ist ja keine Last, solange keiner kommt, geht es ja auch nicht raus. Anbieten kannst du es ja die ganze Zeit.
Schöne neue BitTorrent Welt. Wenn ihr euch beteiligen wollt an der Diskussion, ruft hier einfach 0331 70 97 110. Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir hören jetzt mal ein Stückchen aktuelle Musik aus einem Film. Berlin Calling heißt der Film. Denn es ist schon total aufgeregt.
Fandest du gut?
Dann hören wir mal rein und danach reden wir weiter über BitTorrents. Nicht, weil du vom Rechner hängst, auch mal ins Kino gehst. Berlin Calling heißt der Film, Paul Kalkbrenner spielt die Hauptrolle und hat auch die Musik gemacht. Habt ihr gehört auf Fritz um 11. Und das ist es.
Und das ist es.
Und das ist es. Und das ist es. Und das ist es.
Dennis Krüggs von Erdgeist vom CCC sind hier. Ihr seid eingeladen mit anzurufen, zu diskutieren und Fragen zu stellen unter der 0331 70 97 110.
Und das hat Thomas gemacht, namen Thomas.
Grüß dich, von wo rufst du an?
Aus Hannover, alles klar. Super.
Und zwar habt ihr auf dem letzten 24C3 davon berichtet, dass ihr einen IP-Adressen Zufriedsgenerator eingespielt habt. Und ihr hattet ja auch eure Software an PirateBay weiter in dem. Und da wollte ich mal nachhaken, ob dieser IP-Zufriedsgenerator auch bei PirateBay funktioniert oder läuft.
Okay, also die Sache ist die, dass wir nennen es jetzt mal hier die Mitfahrtzentrale, dass auch nicht nur du dort Informationen kriegst, wer eine bestimmte Datei tauscht, sondern sagen wir mal, wenn da jemand ermittelt oder so die Musikfilmindustrie oder ein Spielhersteller, der kann halt auch dorthin gehen und wenn da ein Spiel getauscht wird zum Beispiel, dann können die sagen, gib mal alle Adressen, die aktuell dieses Spiel irgendwie tauschen. So, da wären dann irgendwie alle Adressen dabei, zum Beispiel auch deine. Und damit würden die dann irgendwie loswandern und würden dich irgendwie, was schicken die heutzutage, eine Abmahnung oder irgendwie, irgendwann schicken sie dir halt einen Brief und so damit die halt keine 100%igen Beweis haben, mischen wir halt eine Zufalls IP-Adresse mit rein. Mal machen wir es, mal nicht, kann man nicht wissen und die wissen es auch nicht. Das heißt, die könnten deine Adresse bekommen haben, weil wir die zufällig erstellt haben. Das heißt, du könntest wiederum sagen, wenn die zu dir kommen, kann ja sein, dass ihr meine Adresse habt, aber von mir ist die nicht. Und wenn euch mehr erkundigt, die Jungs haben die da einfach per Zufall reingemixed. Ich warte gar nicht und mehr ist das nicht. Das läuft nur da. Das ist im Code auch nicht drin, weil den haben wir selber zusammengehackt, weil den soll halt keiner haben. Das machen wir so, wie wir es halt denken nicht, dass die unseren schlechten Zufallscode knacken und dann beweisen können, wie wir auf den gekommen sind oder irgendwie so. Deswegen gibt es den nur bei PirateBay, wenn du bei uns unseren Sourcecode auscheckst, von dem OpenTracker nämlich, kann man gleich noch erzählen, dann ist der nicht mehr drin. Da kann sich auch jeder selber reinbasseln. Das ist ja ganz easy. Du brauchst einfach dir nur eine IP-Adresse einfallen lassen und dann schmeißt du die da rein und lieferst die mit aus. Und das war es schon so. Eine andere Frage, die du noch vorhin gestellt hattest, die hast du jetzt, glaube ich, unterschlagen war, ob wir denn das UDP-Protokoll mit unterstützen in unserem Trecker oder halt auch PirateBay. Und das ist der Fall. Wir unterstützen das schon seit einem Jahr jetzt und läuft auch ziemlich prima. Also kann man nur empfehlen, weil UDP macht weniger Last für den Trecker als TCP, weil wenn man mal Zahlen nennt von PirateBay, die sind bei 25 Millionen Nutzern gerade und UDP ist irgendwie drei bis viermal weniger Traffic so in der Richtung und das spart denen eine Menge irgendwie Traffic, CPU-Zeit, müssen sie weniger Rechner kaufen und die bei PirateBay verdienen auch nicht wirklich viel. Also gar nichts eigentlich an der Sache, sondern die müssen das auch irgendwie zusammensponsoren. Na, das läuft überhaupt nicht, weil die dürfen halt auch kein Geld verdienen.
Erzähl doch mal, was PirateBay ist erstmal, Dennis.
Ja, dann sind wir aber auch fertig mit dir, glaube ich, als Hörer. Tut mir leid.
Das war jetzt so im Schnelldurchlauf. Zack, Zack, Zack, Zack, Zack, Info. Danke, Aled. Klar, mach's gut.
Ja, tut mir leid, aber das ist ja dann schon ein nächstes Thema, aber du hörst ja weiter zu. Okay. Eiskalt, ja.
Es war PirateBay viel, also mit dem Tracker, das haben wir jetzt, glaube ich, zu genüge erklärt.
Wir erklären dir, du kommst ja auch noch weiter vor.
Der OpenTracker ist ja auch noch dran.
Genau, also es gibt, wir erwähnen mal PirateBay, was ist PirateBay? Und zwar, wenn du jetzt deinen Sportfilmen hier von deinem Verein, wenn du den halt irgendwie hochladen willst.
Ich mach nicht mal Sport, aber ein Beispiel ist schön.
Ja, wie hoch nicht man. Sport ist Mord, haben wir gestern erst wieder gelernt. Du willst dann deinen Vereinsfilm irgendwo hochladen und denkst dir, alles klar, gucken wir mal, googeln wir so nach Trackern, kommt gleich irgendwie PirateBay, weil PirateBay selbst, wenn man keinen BitTorrent benutzt, alle Leute kennen PirateBay, das sind irgendwie die guten, für manchen sind es auch die total Bösen, je nachdem, das sind die mit dem Piratenschiff vorne auf der Website.
Also um es einfach zu sagen, PirateBay ist einfach quasi so ein Sammelbecken, wo ich nach Torrent suchen kann.
Da kannst du nach Torrent suchen. Genau, das Google der Torrents. Und damit du da suchen kannst, müssen die Torrent-Files ja da auch hinkommen. Also nimmst du dann dein Sportfilm Torrent und lädst das bei PirateBay hoch, die Liste ist dann und dann kann man danach suchen. Dann tippt man ein hier Sportfilm Torrent und dann zack kommt genau dein Torrent-File, klickt man drauf, lädt man das Torrent-File runter, startet es mit seinem eigenen BitTorrent-Client und dann fängt er an. So, da drin ist natürlich auch der...
Das funktioniert aber nur, wenn diese File bei denen komplett ist.
Genau, du musst dieses kleine BitTorrent-File hochladen. Das ist irgendwie, sagen wir mal so, 200 Kilobyte groß, während dein Film, sagen wir mal so 700 Megabyte groß ist. Und das können die schnell mal ausliefern, auch an 10.000 Leute 300 Kilobyte ausliefern, ist kein Problem. So, das laden dann alle runter und dann legen sie los. Und wenn du als Tracker zum Beispiel auch wieder PirateBay eingetragen hast, weil die haben halt ganz viele davon, dann wird auch deren Tracker benutzt. Und deswegen können die auch auf ihrer Webseite anzeigen, das Torrent-File wird gerade von irgendwie 17 Leuten komplett schon angeboten, weil die haben es schon komplett da und 35 laden es irgendwie runter. Dann haben die so ein bisschen Statistiken und so. Die haben dann ein Kommentarsystem für das Torrent. Da kannst du reinschreiben, was ist das für ein scheiß Sportmovie? Oder ist ja voll super klasse.
So was nennen die Sport?
Oder wie kann ich denn hier diesen Film abspielen? Die quatschten ja Deutsch, ich verstehe keinen Ton. Weil PirateBay ist halt in Schweden und so eine Sachen haben.
Aber hatte PirateBay, um das nochmal ganz kurz auszugreifen, hatten die in der Vergangenheit nicht immer wieder Ärger?
Die hatten immer wieder Ärger, weil halt, kann man so sagen, weil die der größte Trecker, der größte Torrent-Suchmaschine weltweit sind und immer noch. Und dann kommt natürlich die Filmindustrie an und will die wegklagen, weil da gibt es natürlich irgendwie alle möglichen Movies auch noch irgendwie vor der Veröffentlichung oder kurz danach.
Aber die liegen ja, wenn ich das jetzt nochmal als Sendung mit der Mausidiotenfrage dazwischen stellen darf.
Jetzt kommt das entscheidend, ich weiß schon, was jetzt kommt.
Nee, aber die Files liegen ja nicht bei PirateBay auf einem Server, sondern die sind ja bei Usern über die ganze Welt verteilt. Und niemand würde ja auf die Idee kommen, Google zu verklagen. So sieht's aus. Oder irgendeine andere Suchmaschine, weil du bei denen sagst, zeig mir mal bitte ein Foto vom Büro vom Chaos Computer Club.
Und die bei Google haben sogar noch viel mehr, weil die haben ja wirklich, die cashen ja irgendwie Teile der Seiten, wobei es jetzt wirklich nur ist ein bisschen Text, aber die bei PirateBay, die haben wirklich nur noch dieses Torrent-File, wo Prüf-Summen von dem eigentlichen Film oder der eigentlichen Datei drin sind, aber die haben nicht die Datei selber, die haben die auch nie gesehen, nie angefasst. Die wissen auch nicht, wenn du anstelle von deinem Sportfilm da einen... Jugendradio, irgendetwas anderes reinmachst, das wissen die nicht. Die wissen nur, da sind so Prüf-Summen drin und das soll wohl so heißen, aber alles andere interessiert die nicht. Und der Trecker, der das nachher handelt und die einzelnen Leute miteinander verbindet später, der weiß eigentlich noch viel weniger, weil der kriegt irgendwie nur so einen langen Hasch, 20 Zeichen. Mehr weiß der nicht.
Die Frage, die vielen Leuten auf der Zunge liegt, ist, ist das Benutzen von Torrent-Clients und PirateBay legal?
Ja, würde ich auch sagen, das Benutzen an sich ist legal. Wenn du natürlich da böse Sachen machst, die weltweit geahndet werden, dann kommen die natürlich, dann sind die hinter dir her. Aber auch der von PirateBay, der ist da ziemlich schmerzlos, dem ist das alles egal. Da gab es letztens den Fall, der hat sich da echt keine Freunde gemacht, aber der ist halt auch ein bisschen, setzt sich da durch, wurden glaube ich die Obduktionsfotos eines kleinen Mädchens, was in Schweden irgendwie zu Tode gekommen ist, die auch immer sind, bei PirateBay gelandet. Und der Vater hat halt darum gebeten, dass die da drunter genommen werden.
Verständlicherweise.
Peter, ja, wenn man länger drüber nachdenkt, vielleicht dann irgendwann nicht mehr. Also ich hab auch gedacht, muss er jetzt nicht sein, dann dachte ich irgendwann, aber wenn er irgendwo mit einer Sache anfängt, dann drunter nimmt er, irgendwann muss er tausend Sachen runternehmen, das geht halt irgendwie nicht. Und laut Gesetz ist es auch legal in Schweden, so eine Fotos, Obduktionsberichte sind für jeden frei zugänglich. Das ist eine ganz normale Sache da in Schweden. Deswegen konnten die PirateBay auch noch nicht dicht machen, weil PirateBay an sich ist auch legal in Schweden, in Deutschland weiß ich gar nicht, ob es legal wäre.
Also wenn ich PirateBay in Schweden nutze, ist alles cool in Deutschland.
Wenn du das von hier aus nutzt, ist halt die Frage. Das kommt ja auch immer noch auf den Inhalt an. Wenn du da irgendein illegales Spiel runterlädst und das ist ein deutsches Spiel und die deutsche Firma ist dahinter her, dann sind die hinter dir her. Wenn die das irgendwie mitkriegen, kommt die halt an PirateBay nicht an.
Aber das macht ja doch keiner. Es geht ja nur darum, den Sportfilm runterzuziehen.
Gibt es auch Leute, da gibt es auch ab und zu mal Ärger. Es gibt ja in Amerika immer Fälle, wo die da so ein bisschen rumklagen. Und noch ein paar Userzahlen will ich rausführen, weil wir haben die ja gerade so.
Dann kommen wir zu Emil, der hat angerufen.
Da gibt es 25 Millionen aktive PirateBay-Nutzer und die haben anderthalb Millionen Torrents gelistet, aktiv immer so pro, also jetzt so. Also jetzt gerade hat PirateBay 1, 5 Millionen Torrents, die sind irgendwie, worum sie sich kümmern. Das sind morgen wieder andere, aber immer noch so anderthalb Millionen.
Ich glaube, Emil hat Blutgeleck, der hat uns nämlich angerufen unter 0331 70 97 1S0. Name, Emil. Grüß dich. Du hast eine technische Frage zum Thema Server.
Genau.
Schieß los.
Ja, wie richtet man sich eigentlich so ein Server zu Hause ein? Also wenn ich jetzt eine eigene Webseite machen möchte, wie stelle ich die sozusagen ohne ein Hoster ins Internet?
Na, die können dir sagen, such dir irgendwie dünn den, erst mach den Account und dann weiß ich nicht, wenn du noch eine Frage zu BitTorrent hast, können wir dir helfen, ansonsten ist es gut, passt gut.
Ja und wie packt man überhaupt BitTorrent auf diesen Server auch auf? Also dass alle Leute dann diese Dateien haben können, ohne dass man jetzt PirateBay oder so verwendet.
Also um nochmal auf die Frage zurückzukommen, um das Beispiel nochmal zu benutzen, ich habe einen Film gedreht, hab den jetzt, der steht bei mir, liegt bei mir auf meinem Computer, auf meiner Festplatte und ich möchte den dann alle Leute verteilen.
Und der will jetzt seinen eigenen Tracker aufmachen. Na dann lädst du dir einen Tracker deiner Wahl runter. Wir würden natürlich unseren OpenTracker empfehlen. Komplirierst du den, also baust du den für dein Betriebssystem. Wo kriege ich den, den OpenTracker? Da muss Erdgeist die Adresse durchpusten.
Einfach in Google einladen, der zweite Hit ist es.
Bei Google OpenTracker und BitTorrent ein, dann müsste der eigentlich irgendwie mit Eiffel Lucky kommen. Dann startest du den und trägst deine eigene Adresse dann sozusagen als mitfahrzentrale Adresse für den BitTorrent, wie sagt man, für den BitTorrent-File ein.
Dit, BitTorrent-File.
Dit, BitTorrent-File. Ich bin Berliner.
Dit-Torrent.
Emil, Frage beantwortet. Ihr könnt natürlich auch Fragen stellen. Wir haben jetzt schon kurz über PirateBay gesprochen. Wir haben den OpenTracker eben gerade erwähnt. Vielleicht noch mal drei, vier Szenen zum Thema OpenTracker.
Das geben wir jetzt wirklich mal an den Erdgeist, weil der hatte ja zusammengeschustert und deswegen das ist ja sein Baby.
Viel gerade Handarbeit wahrscheinlich.
Schußt dann auch.
So, Erdgeist, OpenTracker. Wir haben vor zwei Jahren angefangen, waren wir der Meinung, dass BitTorrent ein total cooles Medium ist, so Dennis und Krüggs und ich. Und dass man allen zur Verfügung stellen sollte, die Dateien miteinander austauschen wollen. Die sollen BitTorrent benutzen können. Und damals war es so gewesen, dass man die ganzen Tracker, die es gab, nur benutzen konnte, wenn man sich vorher angemeldet hat.
Sogar PirateBay musste man sich immer erst anmelden und man durfte auch nur deren Tracker irgendwie benutzen, sonst durfte man bei PirateBay keine Filesuche landen.
Genau, es war ziemlich blöd. Dann haben wir gesagt, stellen wir mal eine eigene Version von so einem BitTorrent-Tracker ins Internet. Und haben den von Bram Cohn genommen, der irgendwie in Python geschrieben war. Und naja, da hat sich durch Mundpropaganda weiterverteilt, dass man da diese Midware-Zentrale benutzen kann. Und alle Leute, die da mal schnell eine Datei austauschen wollten, haben dann den genommen. Und dann wurde das immer größer und größer. Und das schon bei Dennis in der Küche. Und der Server wurde ganz heiß und dann haben wir gesagt, mh?
Meine Leitung war dann irgendwann dicht. Da ging nichts mehr, nur durch Treckeranfragen.
Genau, weil wenn halt nur genug Leute kommen und genug Leute andere Leute suchen, dann macht das plötzlich auch wieder Verkehr. Also sind wir dann auf einen anderen Server umgezogen. Und der war dann auch bald dicht. Und zwar auf eine Art und Weise, dass halt das Programm einfach so langsam gewesen ist. Und da so eine Mitvertragung nicht viel zu tun hat, als irgendwie Verbindungen annehmen, das einzutragen und wieder was rauszugeben und das irgendwie auch über das HTTP-Protokoll macht, also das, was in einem Browser normalerweise auch spricht, hab ich dann leichtsinnigerweise gesagt, das ist ja halt nur ein Web-Server, das kann man mal schnell selber programmieren. Naja, dann hab ich mich da hingesetzt und das mal schnell selber programmiert und dann...
Du hast das Wort leichtsinnigerweise benutzt und mal schnell selber programmiert.
Also die erste Version war schon nach zweieinhalb Wochen fertig, aber da ist ja immer noch was zu tun. Und naja, also wir haben das Programm dann gestartet und hatten uns dann erst gewundert, ob es denn überhaupt läuft, weil es dann einfach nicht mehr aufgetaucht ist in der Prozesslast- Ansicht. War halt einfach dann immer in C und nicht in Python geschrieben und war dann gleich mal um Größenordnung schneller. Und dann war ich erst mal eine Weile stolz und hab nichts mehr gemacht und dann irgendwann waren es dann doch so viele Leute gewesen, dass man dann nochmal optimieren musste. Da waren dann sowas wie mehrere tausend Leute, die dann pro Sekunde einfach mal bei dieser Mitfahrtzentrale vorbeigekommen sind. Und inzwischen war dann auch der Server, den wir uns dafür gemietet haben. Da kam dann der Host da, bei dem wir den Rechner hingestellt haben, kam an und die wollten auch seriös Geld sehen dafür, dass da so viele Pakete drüber gehen. War schon Anfang dieses Jahres, ja. Genau, aber glücklicherweise hatte dann PirateBay, die auch ähnliche Probleme hatten, dass ihr Tracker auch nicht so schnell war, haben dann das Programm entdeckt und haben es dann bei sich installiert und fanden es total toll und dann durften wir mit unserem eigenen offenen Tracker auf einen von ihren Servern ziehen.
Und so zufrieden, wie du diesen Satz gerade beendet hast, mit den unterschiedlichen Aspekten zwischendurch, scheint die Büchse zu laufen, um es ganz volkszümlich zu sagen.
Mehrere Büchse, die bei PirateBay hatten am Anfang irgendwie 16 Rechner oder so. Inzwischen sind es nur noch 10, weil unsere Software so viel besser ist, dass sie sich ein paar Rechner einsparen konnten.
Und das bei noch mehr Kunden. Du wolltest gerade eine Frage stellen.
Nee, du warst durch mit deinem. Dann würde ich nämlich wieder in die Telefonleiste greifen. 0331 70 97 110. Wir haben eine Anfrage von Bernd. Hallo Bernd, guten Abend.
Hallo Abend. Die Post, die Aztereu zum Beispiel aufmacht, kann da jemand anderes von außerhalb auf meinen Rechner zugreifen?
Nein, der kann halt nur, dein BitTorrent-Programm macht ja diesen Port auf. Und dann können die natürlich von außen auf dein BitTorrent zugreifen. Wenn du jetzt irgendwie File XY irgendwie da drüber anbietest und die auch genau das haben wollen, dann können die sich mit dir austauschen. Aber das ist ja auch Sinn der Sache. Aber wenn die schon sich wegen irgendwas anderem connecten oder sogar ein anderes File, dann kriegen die es nicht. Erstens hast du es wahrscheinlich gar nicht. Und zweitens würde das BitTorrent-Programm sagen, ne, das kann ich nicht und kann ich nicht annehmen.
Also durch den Ruder könnt ihr nicht durchgreifen. Und über den Alter Port geht nur in eine Richtung sozusagen.
Ne, der geht in beide Richtungen. Aber dein BitTorrent-Client würde sozusagen anfragen, die da ankommen, mit denen er nichts anfangen kann, die wirft er weg.
Also mit so einem IP-Scanner oder so kann da keiner zugreifen.
Mit deinem was?
IP-Scanner. Gibt der IP-Scanner, wo andere Leute auf andere Hände greifen.
Ein Portscanner meinst du? Ja doch, kann er. Also dann sieht er, wenn deine Firewall den Port an deinen BitTorrent kleinen durchreicht, dann kann er auch sehen, dass da ein Port offen ist. Aber das bringt in dem ersten Moment mal noch nichts.
Ich glaube die Frage von Bernd zielt nochmal auf das vorhin kurz angesprochene, die angesprochene Problematik, wie sicher ist BitTorrent?
Wenn der BitTorrent kleinen schlecht programmiert ist und der hat irgendeine Lücke, die man ausnutzen kann, dann ist es natürlich genauso wie jedes andere Port, wie Windows oder was auch immer, den man über einen offenen Port irgendwie angreifen kann. Gab es schon mal. Ja gut, aber ansonsten können die nicht dein Filesystem darüber einsehen oder deine Files sehen oder sonst irgendwas, sondern nur das, was du auch anbietest, ist das, was die sehen könnten, wenn sie die richtigen Informationen haben.
Also kurze Ja-Nein-Antwort an Bernd. Muss er sich Sorgen machen?
Glaub nicht.
Alles klar. Bernd, du kannst ruhig schlafen. 03317797110 Chaos Radio Teil 141 auf Fritz zum Thema BitTorrent. Ähm, ja ach so, ja, was auf jeden Fall noch auf der Liste stand, der Dinge, die zu besprechen sind, was will ich jetzt sagen, sind die häufigsten Torrents, die im Moment vorkommen. Du hast gesagt, es gibt 25 Millionen User im Moment mit einer gigantischen Summe an Torrents.
Anderthalb Millionen. Wir haben in unserem Trecker, ich bin halt so Statistikgeil, ich hab mir einbaut lassen von Erdgeist, ich brauch hier Statistik, machen wir irgendwie Top 5. Und jetzt hab ich mir sogar das auf Top 10 erweitert.
Erdgeist ist froh, dass er gerade den O-Source-Tracker durch hat.
Ja, die sind ja schon drin. Außerdem brauchen wir die, weil ich meine, um zu sehen, was er verbessern muss, müssen wir sehen, was wie wo passiert und wie viel und wie oft und so weiter. Und dann kann man so ein Ding optimieren. Jedenfalls haben wir da auch eine Top 10 drinnen. Und das, was immer ganz oben ist, sind amerikanische Serien.
Was für amerikanische Serien?
Heroes oder Dexter.
Also es gibt da Statistiken bei PirateBay. Es gibt da eine andere Website, die nennt sich taurenfreak.com und die bringen, glaube ich, zweimal in der Woche eine Statistik raus, welche die beliebtesten Tauren-Files auf PirateBay sind. Und da gibt es halt so eine Top 10 für Serien und eine Top 10 für Filme. Und da sind die Serien halt extrem beliebt. Einfach weil die Leute sie sofort sehen wollen und nicht warten wollen, bis es in Deutschland die schlechte Synchronisation mit den Werbepausen gibt. Oder weil sie halt einfach den Privatkanalen nicht bekommen, auf denen diese Dinger laufen.
Wenn man jetzt mal bedenkt, dass irgendwie, ich würde schon sagen, auch am meisten also BitTorrent von den Amis benutzt wird und die Amis dann amerikanische Serien runterladen, möchte ich nicht wissen, weil wir wieder von ihr, ob das legal ist, und so sprechen. Wie viel von den Leuten, die halt Heroes zum Beispiel runterladen, das auch gleich so im Fernsehen sehen könnten. Vielleicht haben die gar keinen Bock auf Fernsehen, oder vielleicht haben die gar kein Fernseher mehr. Das wissen wir nicht.
Das kann sein, oder aber sie haben keinen Bock darauf, dass die Fernsehserie ihnen in 25 Teile zerhackt wird, wo zwischendurch Werbung läuft und dann...
Das wäre doch dann schon wieder illegal. Man darf ja wohl Werbung nicht wegschneiden, oder? Das ist ja auch verboten irgendwie so seine...
Aber Tiwo macht das doch auch.
Ja, aber da wird doch schon wieder gegen geklagt, gegen Videorekorder die Werbung rausschneiden.
Folgender Vorschlag, wir klären mal ganz kurz, ihr hört ein Stückchen Musik, dann ist das Chaosradio gleich zurück. Luomo heißt der junge Mann. Kommt aus Finnland gemeinsam mit Sascha Ring aus Berlin alias Apparat. Love you all im Chaosradio auf Ritz am Mittwochabend, 26. November um 5 vor halb 12. Dennis Krügs und Erdgeist sind hier vom CTC und wir reden über BitTorrent. Sind schon eine Menge Begriffe gefallen, paar haben wirklich klärt. Der Tracker zum Beispiel, den hat Erdgeist wunderbar umschrieben als die Mittfahrtzentrale. Aber wir hatten das noch nicht mit den WearSites und SearchSites und MetaSearchSites. Das viel vorhin schon mal ganz kurz, da könntet ihr noch mal genauer drauf eingehen.
Also eine SearchSite ist eigentlich nichts anderes als ein Google, was in Torrents sucht. Wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel PiedPenem oder andere Seiten wie Isohand oder was gibt es noch? Torrent, TU, Mininova, das sind eigentlich nur Web-Server, die eine Datenbank haben, in denen diese Torrent-Files rumliegen. Und diese Torrent-Files, die kann man halt kommentieren und diesen Kommentaren kann man suchen. Man muss sich das wie Google vorstellen, aber nur eine Suche auf Torrent-Dateien. Und das Neueste, was es jetzt wohl geben wird und was dann wahrscheinlich so der nächste Schritt sein wird, ist, dass die Leute anfangen, wirklich auch die Google-Engine, die ja beliebt ist. Also Google ist halt einfach mal die Suchmaschine im Internet, dass die Leute anfangen dagegen dafür Applikationen zu schreiben, die dann diese Google-Search-Engine benutzen, um über mehrere Torrent-Search-Sites, die es da draußen gibt, also er sucht dann nicht nur bei PirateBay und nicht nur bei Mininova, sondern halt bei allen, die es so gibt. Und da kann man dann natürlich wesentlich besser Dateien finden, auch abgefahrenes Zeug kann man da finden und Sachen, die es halt nur bei dem einen und nicht bei dem anderen gibt. Und das ist so die Sache, in die es jetzt gehen wird wahrscheinlich, so Meta-Torrent-Suchmaschinen.
Also eine Suchmaschine, die verschiedene Torrents, die andere Suchmaschinen durchsucht. Die formuliert jetzt irgendwie bildlich an, also einer, der sozusagen alle Läden durch Co-Pros das geben könnte, und nicht nur eine einzige. Okay. Wie ist das mit den Wear Sites?
Mit den Wear Sites?
Na ja, was es wohl noch gibt, sind so geschlossene BitTorrent-Systeme. Ich selber bin auf so ein Ding ja nicht, da muss man sich irgendwie anmelden und Leute kennen und invite-ownen und dieses ganze Elite-Schnick-Schnack und so ein Zeug. Und da hab ich ja keinen Bock drauf. Weil das sind auch, denn das sind wirklich die Dinger, die dann hochgenommen werden, weil die übertreiben es einfach.
Die verdienen auch noch Geld damit.
Die wollen Kohle oder sind irgendwie so weit vorne, dass der Bond schon eine Woche vorher da ist oder so. Und da bin ich einfach nicht dabei.
Aber sind diese geschlossenen Netzwerke, um nochmal ganz am Anfang für die kommerzielle Umgebung, die auf die kommerzielle Nutzung zurückzukommen, nicht interessant für Firmen, die, weiß ich nicht, ein Software-Abdeck anbieten.
Von der Software her vielleicht, vom Inhalt natürlich.
Aber nur für die User, die diese Software benutzen. Also wenn Microsoft jetzt sagt, wir haben ein neues Patch für unser Betriebssystem, und das gibt es jetzt aber nur für Leute, die das gekauft haben oder so, dass man das abschließt. Oder bei WoW war das so ein Closing?
Also von der Software ist es für die Firmen bestimmt interessant, aber ob es am Ende wirklich so funktioniert, ist nicht ganz so easy. Weil wenn ich erstmal einen BitTorrent Client gefunden hab, der irgendwie ein Programm, was so eine Firma halt kommerziell irgendwie per BitTorrent verteilt, wenn ich den erstmal hab und mit dem irgendwie tauschen kann, dass der mir auch die Informationen der anderen Mitfahrer gibt, dann kann ich ja was runterladen, was ich eigentlich hätte bezahlen müssen. Und dann, das wollen die ja nicht. Und das ist ein bisschen schwierig zu erklären. Es gibt so eine BitTorrent Erweiterung der Clients, das heißt Peer Exchange. Dadurch können sich Peers untereinander auch noch Adressen austauschen, ohne dass sie die Mitfahrzentrale fragen müssen. Und das kann nicht Sinn in so einer Firma sein.
Aber wie war das bei Blizzard und bei WoW, beim letzten Patch für World of Warcraft?
Das ist ja was, denen ist es ja egal. Das kann ja jeder haben.
Das konnte man auch mit einem normalen Torrent-Client runterladen, wenn man den machte.
Genau. Also bei Blizzard macht es so, die schicken einem immer so ein Mini-Update, das ist irgendwie so ein Megabyte groß. Und dieses Megabyte ist nicht ein Torrent-File, sondern ist sogar ein Programm. Und innerhalb dieses Programms, weil das nämlich eigentlich ein BitTorrent-Client ist, ist auch gleich das Torrent-File und dann startest du das Programm und dann geht eigentlich ein BitTorrent-Client auf, so ein Selbstgemachter mit irgendwie Blizzard-Bildchen oder WoW-Bildchen. Und der fängt dann an runterzuladen. Erstens von Blizzard selbst.
Also um das Patch zu würzen, weil du hast das Spiel ja gekauft. Aber wenn es irgendwie neues Add-On geben würde, kann ich den Laden geben, mir die Software kaufen.
Das musst du sowieso freischalten lassen. Und dann ist Blizzard auch egal, wenn du den Patch runterlädst und aber nicht freigeschaltet hast, kannst du ja auch nichts damit anfangen.
Das ist denen egal.
Aber so richtig, dass es kommerziell BitTorrent benutzt wird, ist mir auch nicht bekannt. Also kommerziell. Dass Daten nur an Leute verteilt werden, die dafür bezahlt haben, kenne ich eigentlich nicht. Kommt aber bestimmt auch noch. Das ist ja das, wo wahrscheinlich auch BitTorrent dort kommen, also die Firma von dem Brand Kohnen, wo die dran arbeiten. Weil die haben sich ja irgendwann auch, glaube ich, Venture Capital von Warner geholt oder so.
Ich würde noch gerne einen Anrufer herannehmen. Wir hatten ja vorhin schon erwähnt, einer der großen Nachteile von BitTorrent ist, dass eigentlich nur aktuell verfügbare Daten vorhanden sind. Also, was die Leute aktuell gerade haben wollen, wenn du irgendwas brauchst.
Oder eine Firma, die sich halt drum kümmert, wie Blizzard das ganze Zeit anbietet hat.
Oder der Chaos Computer Club, die die Filme der letzten ganzen Kongresse auch immer noch anbieten. Veit hat dazu eine Frage. Hallo Veit, guten Abend. Das ist hier gar nicht genau zu sehen. Grüß dich, Veit.
Hi, ich hab eine Frage. Zum Beispiel so ganz alte Sachen von 99 oder sowas, Voyager oder so ein Kram. Gibt es noch irgendeine Möglichkeit, dass man überall im Web, also dass man halt das Server dafür abstellt, die dir die ganzen Sachen immer weiter sharen, dass man dann diese wichtigen nicht verliert?
Also, solange jemand da ist, der irgendwie diese alten Filme, welche auch immer das sind, weil Voyager, weiß nicht wie es so legalmäßig aussieht, aber wenn jemand da ist, der dir die ganze Zeit anbietet, weil er ein Fan ist oder weil er Interesse dran hat, dass sich die Sachen verteilen, dann sind auch Sachen von 99 noch im Netz, wenn aber keiner da ist, dann geht das schlecht und meistens lassen für alte Sachen, lässt das Interesse nach einer Weile nach, dann will es keiner mehr haben. Also zum Beispiel ein Film, ich nehme jetzt mal als Beispiel 2001 diesen Space Odyssey, der ist von 69, den gibt es auch noch im Netz, weil den gucken immer noch tausende Leute, aber irgendein Scheiß, den halt keiner sehen will, den gibt es auch nicht. Aber das ist eigentlich mit allen Sachen so, oder?
Wenn sich der rechte Inhaber von Voyager dazu bequemen würde, dass die Fans noch weiter die Serie sehen können, dann würde er dafür sorgen, dass im BitTorrent die Voyager-Folgen immer noch verfügbar wären.
Veit, du siehst auch hier greift das alte Oma Stichwort, die Kette ist immer nur so stark wie ihr schlechtes Glied.
Wird am diesjährigen CZT über BitTorrent gesprochen?
Also wir haben keinen Vortrag eingebracht.
Nicht von uns, wenn es jemand macht, aber ich habe bisher nichts gesehen, glaube ich. Und wir wollten nicht das Gleiche wie im letzten Jahr erzählen, weil irgendwann ist es auch nicht mehr so spannend. Vielleicht im nächsten Jahr wieder.
Nein.
Alter, wir haben eine Grußsendung und eine Wunschsendung bei Fritz. Schick ihm ne Mail. MeinFritz.de heißt die. Läuft jeden Tag zwischen 19 und 20 Uhr. Da kannst du das machen. Und der eigentliche Trick, den verrate ich jetzt mal, ist nicht zu sagen, kann ich noch jemanden grüßen, sondern ich würde gerne mal Paul Erwin, Egon und Willi grüßen. Dann ist das in Ordnung. Dann würde ich sagen, ist natürlich nicht in Ordnung. Feiert dir einen schönen Abend.
Und Paul und Volker, mein schwules Bärchen, begrüße ich noch sehr.
Ciao.
Manchen ist ihre Musik zu anti. Anderen ist ihre Bühnenshow. Aber die meisten kriegen einfach nicht too much von diesem Anti. Die Gewinner des Radio Awards für neue. Live in Berlin und Live in Cottbus. Wann genau und wo genau? Genau. Sind Sie too much? Seid ihr zu.
Bei Terroranschlägen im indischen Bombay sind bis zu 80 Menschen ums Leben gekommen. Mehr als 200 wurden verletzt. Das berichten indische Behörden. Ein Verwaltungssprecher teilte mit, dass auch mehrere Ausländer als Geiseln verschleppt worden sind. Die Attentäter griffen verschiedene Luxushotels, einen Café, einen gelebten Bahnhof und eine Tankstelle an. In einem der Hotels befanden sich offenbar auch EU-Politiker. Ob unter den Opfern auch Deutsche sind, ist immer noch nicht geklärt. Zu den Anschlägen hat sich in verschiedenen E-Mails eine islamistische Gruppe bekannt. In Thailand halten Regierungsgegner weiter den Flughafen in Bangkok besetzt. Hunderte Flüge wurden abgesagt, tausende Urlauber sitzen fest. Mit der Aktion wollten die Demonstranten die Rückkehr vom thailändischen Ministerpräsidenten Somchai von einer Auslandsreise verhindern. Er landete aber stattdessen auf eine Militärflughafen im Norden des Landes. Die Regierungsgegner werfen Ministerpräsident Somchai unter anderem Korruption vor und verlangen deshalb auch seinen Rücktritt. In diesem Wintersemester gibt es offenbar so viele Studienanfänger wie noch nie. Die Wochenzeitung Die Zeit hat ausgerechnet, dass sich 334.000 junge Leute neu eingeschrieben haben. Das sind gut 6% mehr als im letzten Jahr. Demnach haben vor allem das Saarland, Hessen und Hamburg bei den Studienanfängern zugelegt. Aber auch in Brandenburg gab es einen Studentenansturm. Die Zahlen will das Statistische Bundesamt am Montag offiziell rausgeben. Werder Bremen muss sich aus der Champions League verabschieden. Die Bremer kamen bei Anautosis Famagusta lediglich zu einem 2 zu 2. Damit blieben sie auch im fünften Spiel ohne Sieg. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen heute Nacht in Frankfurt und Cottbus haben wir 3 Grad, Potsdam und Angermünde 4, Neurupien 5, Wittenberge 6 und auch in Berlin sind es 5 Grad. Heute Nacht ist es stark bewölkt. Es gibt immer wieder Regen oder auch Sprühregen und die Temperaturen gehen bis auf 2 Grad runter. Auch am Tag ist es ziemlich bewölkt. Vor allem im Norden kann es noch etwas regnen. In südlicher Richtung kommt auch mal die Sonne raus. Das Ganze dann bei maximal 7 Grad. Mit einer Meldung aus dem Stadtverkehr Berlin immer noch auf der A100 Stadtring Richtung Wedding zwischen Spandauer Damm und dem Siemens Damm 1 Kilometer Stau. Wir wünschen euch eine gute Fahrt.
Und wenn im Radio 89, 85, dann Fritz in Berliner Kabel.
Blum, die Zeitsprechstunden.
Der Chaos Computer Club begrüßt euch zum Chaos Radio. Achso, der hängt direkt vor deiner Nase. Das Ding, wo die rote Lampe darüber leuchtet. Und wenn du da reinsprichst, können wir dich alle hören. Also Erdgeist war das, der ist schon da. Dennis und Kröck sind auch hier. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir reden heute über BitTorrent und haben vorhin ja ganz kurz schonmal angewähnt, dass mittlerweile mehr als 50% des Traffic, der im Netz passiert, per Torrent betrieben wird, wo natürlich jeder handelsübliche DSL-Handbieter, der euch eine Flatrate zur Verfügung stellt, vor Schreck in die Hände klatscht. Was passiert denn da genau?
Ja, eigentlich sollten sie sich ja freuen, dass die Leute anfangen, ihr DSL zu benutzen und auch dieses Internet mal zu benutzen. Aber das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Sie müssen ja den Traffic, den sie an die Endkunden weitergeben, die müssen sie auch irgendwo einkaufen. Die müssen sie irgendwo bezahlen. Und wenn man zu Hause eine Flatrate hat, dann zahlt man den selber nicht. Da zahlt man dann 20 Euro im Mond und das ist gut. Und wenn man da jetzt aber die 16 MBit 24-7 dichtmacht, dann muss der Provider das irgendwo einkaufen. Und die verschiedene Provider haben jetzt angefangen, das nicht mehr so gut zu finden und rauszufinden, was dann jetzt eigentlich diesen Traffic produziert. Und sind darauf gekommen, okay, es ist tatsächlich bitter und was bei uns diese Probleme verursacht. Deswegen wir so viel Traffic einkaufen müssen, den wir gar nicht refinanziert bekommen durch das 20 Euro, die wir im Preis erhöhen, das klingt erstmal nach Preiserhöhungen, kann man aber nicht machen, der Markt ist hart. Es gibt immer jemanden, der weniger für seinen DSL-Anschluss haben will. Und die Provider haben halt angefangen BitTorrent zu shapeen. Sie fangen also an, das Protokoll zu erkennen und fangen dann an die Datenrate runter zu drehen. Sie werfen Pakete weg oder halten sie eine Weile auf.
Also das merke ich dann daran, dass es mehr dauert?
Das merkt man dann daran, dass da keine vernünftige Datenrate zustande kommt, dass man da nicht mehr als einen Megabyte pro Sekunde runterladen kann oder ein Mbit oder so. Und dann sitzt man halt doof da und es ist schon mehrfach vorgekommen, dass große Providers das getan haben. In Amerika war es wohl der DSL Provider Comcast, der da im Gespräch war, der hat das getan. In Deutschland, weiß ich gar nicht, ob es da auch schon einen Fall gab. Jedenfalls ist es ein Problem. Kabel Deutschland war das, glaube ich.
Das Problem ist ja auch, dass die Leute nicht nur runterladen, weil die haben ja 16 Mbit, können ja viel runterladen, sondern die schicken ja auch alle noch hoch, weil jeder tauscht ja mit jedem, es ist ja peer-to-peer. Und das mögen die auch gar nicht. Das kostet nämlich auch richtig.
Aber da gibt es jetzt einen Ansatz dagegen, was zu tun? Also den Ansatz für die BitTorrent-Benutzer, was dagegen zu tun?
Wir haben nämlich dann angefangen, irgendein BitTorrent-Protokoll, Kryptographie einzubauen. Das ist so dasselbe, was du machst, wenn du mit deiner Bank so Transaktionen machst. Dann machst du ja auch HTTPS. Und das ist dann fast wie Internet, bloß in verschlüsselt.
Fast wie Internet, nur verschlüsselt.
Die selbe Idee haben sie sich dann auch für die Verbindung von einem Pier, also von jemanden, der eine Datei runterladen möchte, zu jemand anderem, der eine Datei runterladen möchte, haben sie sich auch ein Krypto-Protokoll ausgedacht, sodass man vielleicht bei der Auswahl seines BitTorrent-Clients, mit dem man Dateien runterladen möchte, einfach darauf achten, dass die auch wirklich Krypto können. Das steht dann auf der Seite drauf, dass irgendwie Encryption oder Krypto oder so steht da drauf. Zum Beispiel Transmission, was irgendwie unsere Empfehlung war, kann das einfach von Hause aus. Und dann, wenn es verschlüsselt ist, dann hat der ISP auch wenig Möglichkeit, zu erkennen, dass es jetzt BitTorrent ist. Also sie können dann vielleicht versuchen, anhand der Muster in den Paketen, noch von draußen, also zeitlich, zu korrelieren, ob das jetzt BitTorrent vielleicht ist oder nicht, aber können sich auch in die Nässin setzen.
Aber sie sehen in jedem Fall, dass das Erdgeist immer noch genauso viel Traffic veranstaltet wie vorher. Sie können nur nicht mehr sagen, was du da machst.
Genau. Und da das ja nur die Hälfte des Problems ist, man ja auch mit dem Tracker noch redet, bin ich jetzt auch dabei, das Krypto in den Trackerverkehr mit einzubauen.
Weil zum Beispiel die ganzen Provider der Welt kennen, wenn wir jetzt mal wieder bei PirateBay sind, die kennen die Adressen von PirateBay, also könnte man jetzt filtern. Jeder, der eine Connection zu PirateBay macht, der will ja irgendwie BitTorrent machen, also lassen wir die Connection schon gar nicht zu, dass er gar nicht bei PirateBay ankommt, und das ist natürlich blöd, also will man da verschlüsseln.
Du hast gesagt, da bin ich gerade dran. Wie lange dauert das, bis wir das alle benutzen können, was du dir da ausdenkst?
Na, das ist halt ziemlich anstrengend für so einen Server.
Ich will mal kurz, du kannst noch drüber nehmen. Also eigentlich wäre Verschlüsselung zum Tracker ganz easy, weil das ist sowieso ein HTTP-Call, so wie dein Webbrowser das auch macht. Man könnte sogar einen BitTorrent-Call zum Tracker im Browser eingeben und würde dann das komische Ergebnis sehen, aber okay, das kriegt halt der Client. Aber da könnte man einfach SSL davor kleben, also hier dieses HTTPS, dass es nicht sicher ist, so wie da bei der Bank oder wo auch immer. Und dann wäre alles gut. Und das könnte man einfach so klick, einschalten und dann würde es gehen. Das Problem ist nur, bei PirateBay kommen so einer Sekunde 50.000, so eine Hits pro Sekunde. Und das kann man nicht verschlüsseln, weil verschlüsseln kostet viel CPU-Zeit. Und es gibt zwar auch Hardware, die ist beschleunigt, aber die ist teuer oder die schafft es auch nicht, weiß nicht genau. Und da kommt Erdgeist dann, weil der muss es hinkriegen. Das ist auch bei 50.000 immer noch funktioniert.
Ich sehe Erdgeist in so einem blauen, komplett engen Trainingsanzug mit so einem großen gelben E auf der Brust mit so einem Umhang. Hier kommt Erdgeist und er wird euch retten. Wie willst du das machen?
Wie ich das machen will, ist jetzt sehr technisch, aber vielleicht... Ich sehe mich eher in so einer Montage wie ein Rocky, wie der jetzt mal auf Klo tippe und mal in der Küche tippe und dann ist es nach einem Monat fertig oder so. Hoffentlich zumindest.
Und wenn das fertig ist und ob das fertig ist?
Das verkünden wir dann lauthals.
Das können wir dann auch auf PirateBay.
Beziehungsweise irgendwie auch bei cdc.de?
Vielleicht in unserem Blog, das können wir eigentlich mal...
Wir würden ihn mal zusätzlich anbieten, auf jeden Fall. Aber den wir bei PirateBay willkommen, halt umschalten.
Das war opentracker.blog.h3q.com. Gibt's da nachher auch einen Wiki? Da war schon eine Weile nicht mehr was geschrieben, weil es schon eine Weile nicht mehr so viel zu berichten gab. Aber eigentlich sind wir da... Ist das unser Sprachrohr?
Im Zweifelsfall verlinkt zu finden unter chaosradio.ccc.de Und da klickt ihr euch zu dieser Sendung durch, die ihr dann natürlich auch noch mal als Podcast ganz in Ruhe hören könnt, wenn ihr mitschreiben wollt und den einen oder anderen Detail noch nicht auf dem Zettel hattet. Haben wir jetzt die wichtigsten Dinge besprochen, die zum Thema BitTorrent auf dem Tisch liegen oder haben wir irgendwas Exzellenzielles vergessen?
Nö, das war's. Wir haben noch so ein bisschen Themen, die nix mit BitTorrent zu tun haben. Wir könnten noch mal zusammenfassen.
Das wäre schön, wenn du noch mal eine Schleife um das Paket machst, damit was alle mitnehmen können.
Genau, wir hatten noch einen Hörer, der wollte unbedingt wissen, welchen BitTorrent Kleinen wir benutzen. Ich selbst benutze Transmission.
Das ist eine Mailcom, genau.
Genau, und die anderen auch.
Genau, unter Windows nimmt man halt Mikrotorrent. Das ist so dieses Mikro, dieses griechische Buchstaben, links ein Torrent dahinter. Oder U-Torrent.
Azurios oder Fuse. Ansonsten zusammenfassend kann man sagen, BitTorrent ist halt ein prima Protokoll, damit man möglichst viele Daten oder eine große Menge an viele Leute verteilen kann, ohne dass man an dem Traffic selbst zusammenbricht. Also dass man nicht die Daten tausendmal für tausend Leute rausschiebt, sondern nur dreimal für tausend Leute rausschiebt und trotzdem es alle kriegen kann.
Interessant für alle Leute, die Bilder, Filme, was auch immer.
Die massenweise verteilen müssen und wo es auch jeder haben kann und es keine Beschränkungen gibt, sondern einfach jeder es kriegen kann, wenn er will. Und dann die Frage, ob es legal ist oder nicht. Es kommt nicht auf das BitTorrent an sich an. Also BitTorrent an sich ist nicht illegal, genauso wie Telefonieren nicht illegal ist, sondern es kommt halt drauf an, was man da drüber betreibt. Also was der Inhalt ist.
So wie HTTP nicht illegal ist, sondern die Dateien, die man über HTTP überträgt. Weil nichts anderes ist BitTorrent, nämlich ein Protokoll, ein Internetprotokoll.
Und legale Anwendungsfälle haben wir ja genug aufgezählt. Open Solaris, FreeBSD, World of Warcraft ist alles mit dabei. Und es wird immer mehr werden, davon kann man ausgehen.
Was sind denn die möglichen Aussichten, wohin sich BitTorrent bewegen könnte? Also was sind die Dinge, wo es noch Veränderungen geben muss, außer den Encryptions, die die Welt noch wartet?
Wir hatten vorhin ja Berlin Calling gehört. Und so wie ich das gesehen hab, wird das Album zum Beispiel nur als Download angeboten. Jetzt schnell vor, hier so ein Künstler wie Paul Kagebrenner will seine neue CD rausbringen und will die möglichst an viele Leute verteilen, dann kann er das halt mit BitTorrent machen. Zum Beispiel. Und wenn die sich irgendwann mal da noch ein Modell einfallen lassen, wie man damit Geld verdient, können wir das irgendwie auch noch einbauen.
Wobei es Berlin Calling auch als CD gibt, seh ich gerade. Kannst du ganz easy kaufen.
Ich hab das nur mal geguckt und hab den nicht gefunden.
Ja, hast du wahrscheinlich nicht geguckt. Er erschienen bei B-Pitch Control, kannst du kaufen für...
Ja, aber nicht als Download, aber nicht als Fest. Na klar.
Die waren halt schlau, die haben halt gesagt, okay, bevor irgendjemand herkommt und unser Album rippt und dann da einen Torrent rausmacht und das irgendwo hintut und wir keine Kontrolle haben, was da in diesem Album ist, tun wir das einfach selber. Und dann wissen wir wenigstens, was da so einigermaßen drin ist und was wir verteilt haben. Und wenn es das schon mal gibt und das irgendwie gut geseadet ist und gut verteilt, dann steht sich noch jemand hin und sagt, okay, ich ripp das jetzt nochmal und tu das nochmal irgendwie nach PirateBay. Das ist ja dann langweilig. Gibt's ja schon.
Also ihr seht, es gibt eine Menge zu entdecken im großen Feld von BitTorrent.
Gerade bei Künstlern, die so klein sind und erstmal groß anfangen wollen, da seh ich das. So wie Radio hat das gemacht letztes Jahr, fand ich auch super. Die wollten zwar auch Geld, aber da könnte auch BitTorrent, glaube ich, in Zukunft irgendwann mal zum Einsatz kommen.
Aber es war kein Torrent-File bei Radio Hat. Das war eine andere Geschichte. Weil bei Torrent hast du ja dann immer den Nachteil, nicht kontrollieren zu können. Du willst das haben, ich hab's auf meiner Seite und ich sag, okay, kostet irgendwie ein Euro.
Oder 50 Cent oder so.
Da gibt's noch keine richtigen Modelle mit BitTorrent. Aber ich denke mir, Leute, die Geld verdienen wollen, die werfen auch immer eine Menge Hirnschmal drauf und lassen sich was einfallen.
Ihr seht, BitTorrent ist ein interessantes Thema. Möglicherweise in einer der laufenden kommenden Sendungen irgendwann mal in den kommenden Monaten oder Jahren werden wir uns dieser ganzen Geschichte noch mal widmen. Wir machen das Thema BitTorrent jetzt erst mal zu. Verweisen euch auf chaosradio.ccc.de, wo ihr einen Podcast zu dieser Sendung kriegt und natürlich auch den Podcast von Chaos Radio Express, die eine ähnlich gelagerte Sendung mit diesem Thema auch schon mal gemacht haben. Und jetzt müssen wir uns noch zwei Sachen widmen, die noch anstehen, denn es ist das letzte Chaos Radio in diesem Jahr. Im Dezember gibt's keins. Denn vom 27. bis zum 30. gibt's wie immer traditionell den Kongress.
Genau, und der Kongress findet im BCC am Alexanderplatz statt. Und Eintritt ist 80 am Mäßigt 35 Euro. Und wir haben wie viele spannende Themen. Wir ziehen da ein eigenes GSM-Netzwerk auf, zum mal damit spielen. Es gibt Vorträge über Pflanzen hacken, Züchten 2.0.
Pflanzen hacken, Züchten 2.0?
Na, das ist wie ein Nerds, die sich da mal intensiv damit auseinandergesetzt haben, wie man so Pflanzen züchtet.
Ach, Pflanzen hacken, also quasi Gartenarbeit 2.0.
Biotechnologie hat heutzutage viel mehr mit Technologie als mit Bio zu tun.
Und ihr baut ein eigenes GSM-Netzwerk?
Wir bauen ein eigenes GSM-Netzwerk. Es gibt einen traditionellen Jahresrückblick.
Ein eigenes Mobilfunk.
Ein eigenes Mobilfunk-Netzwerk.
Ist das denn erlaubt?
Klar, wenn du dir die Frequenz vorher geben lässt, ist das doch erlaubt.
Es gibt ja auch Standard-Hacker, die gehen glatt los und besorgen sich alles, was man wirklich braucht, um das legal machen zu dürfen. Sowas gibt es auch. Die Leute, denen macht das Spaß.
Na, die Amateur-Funk ja doch ziemlich häufig.
Das Motto kannst du mal noch nennen.
Genau, das Motto dieses Jahr ist Nothing to Hide. Nichts zu verbergen.
Ist das ein Fragezeichen oder ein Ausrufzeichen?
Ein Fragezeichen. Alles, was du dir vorstellst, was du da rein interpretieren kannst, soll ja auch zum Denken anregen, was man denn zu verbergen hat. Ob man noch was verbergen kann im Internet, das wir als Chaos Computer Club eigentlich nicht zu verbergen haben, was wir letztes Jahr so alles Tolles geschafft haben, was man sich dann auch in unserem Jahresrückblick da anhören kann.
Und die Ultimate C64 Talk.
Und es gibt den Ultimate C64 Talk, das werde ich mir dann um die mal wohlwollend angucken.
Da gibt es bestimmt einen 64er mit Internetanschluss und wahrscheinlich sogar mit BitTorrent.
Wir müssen doch den Datendaten noch mal sagen.
Mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit. Lass uns das eine kurz zu Ende machen. Also, wenn euch Pflanzen hacken, also Gartenarbeit, Biotechnologie zwischen 2.0, interessiert der C64 Talk oder das eigen angefertigte GSM Netzwerk vom Chaos Computer Club, dann macht euch vom 27. bis zum 30. Dezember auf den Weg nach Berlin ins BCC, das ist direkt am Alexanderplatz, unter dem Motto Nothing to Hide, der diesjährige Kongress.
Da wo die große Rakete steht.
Genau, und wir haben noch einen Überraschungsvortrag zum Ende, den wir aber noch nicht verraten dürfen. Der ganz besonders lustig und spannend ist.
Okay, also wer nicht da ist, ist selber schuld.
Der ist selber schuld.
Krüß, jetzt kannst du was zum Datengarten sagen.
Hier steht auf meinem Zettel noch, wir sollen den Datengarten morgen ansagen.
Was heißt hier steht auf meinem X? Wir sollen, du möchtest.
Ja, wir möchten ihn ansagen. Morgen findet in unseren allerwerten Club-Lokalitäten ein Datengarten statt und zwar zu dem Thema Solarsegler. Das ist an der Marienstraße 11 in 10117 Berlin. Das ist in Mitte, um die Ecke vom S-Bahn auf Friedrichstraße.
Wenn du jetzt noch erklärst, was ein Datengarten ist, ob da jeder kommen kann, der Bock hat und ob ein Solarsegler ist.
Also generell kann eigentlich Donnerstag sowieso in unsere Club-Rolle jeder kommen, der will und uns Löchern nachfragen oder einfach entspannt rum sitzen und klicken.
Donnerstags den Tag, der auf der Tür jeden Donnerstag.
Und Datengarten ist quasi die Erweiterung davon. Dort findet ein Vortrag statt. Jemand kommt und hält einen Vortrag auf dem Beamer und ist der Abend sozusagen einem Thema gewidmet.
Morgen Solarsegler.
Und morgen Solarsegler, genau, und da spricht Karin Remaikes. Und die hat, hier steht, für Planetary Society...
Also Solarsegler. Das ist so was...
Es gibt's doch, morgen wird's auch erklärt.
Das ist total spannend. Das ist so ein Raumschiff, was einfach große Sonnensegel aufspannt und sich vom Sonnenwind durch die Gegend blasen lässt. Und dann... Und das erste Projekt, was so finanziert worden ist, vor zwei oder drei Jahren, das war irgendwie das Cosmos-1-Projekt. Und die haben da versucht, einen Solarsegler zu bauen. Ich glaube, das hat irgendwie nicht so ganz geklappt. Aber das könnt ihr euch dann morgen im Datengarten anhören. Der offene Donnerstag beim CCCB geht immer 17 Uhr los. Und wenn genug Leute da ist, wahrscheinlich 18, 19 Uhr, geht der Vortrag dann los.
Genau, nämlich die Hacker fangen jetzt an. Nachdem sie Drohnen gebaut haben, fangen sie jetzt auch an, Raumschiffe zu bauen.
Okay, ihr macht ja vom 27. bis zum 30. Dezember den Kongress feiern, hackern auch Weihnachten.
Nee, da müssen wir ja aufbauen, den Kongress.
Wenn sie es vermeiden lässt, dann bringt Geschenke mit.
Damit wäre diese Frage auch beantwortet und damit nähert sich dieses Chaosradio Teil 141 im Jahre 2008 auch seinem Ende entgegen. Euch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, für die interessanten Anrufe und Beiträge. Wenn ihr euch noch beteiligen wollt an einer weiteren Diskussion oder sonst die Sendung nochmal hören wollt, chaosradio.ccc.de. Wir hören uns dann im Januar wieder in der letzten Sendung, im letzten Mittwoch, im letzten Mittwoch im Monat im Januar, ist ein neuer Teil fürs Chaosradio. Dennis Krügs und Erdgeiss, euch vielen Dank für die Einblicke in die bunte, komplizierte, merkwürdige und auch interessante Welt von BitTorrent. Hier geht's weiter mit Night Flight, Maxwell Smart ist da, der hat DJ Hype zu Gast. Da gibt's also elektronische Musik und Beats, die im Kopf von Maxwell und Co. wachsen. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, ich schmeiß dich jetzt hinaus in diese Nacht mit Mr. oder Monsieur Oiseau. Bis denn, tschüss.